Three,
two,
this is live,
ladies and gentlemen,
and this is a very unusual podcast we're
going to have here and a very unusual
discussion I have to my left and Michael
Shermer,
very famous skeptic.
He's been on the podcast before,
of course,
Randall Carlson,
amazing gentleman who knows far too much
about terrifying things like asteroids
and Graham Hancock author,
also a fantastic human being,
many times been on this podcast as well,
and this all came out of a podcast that
Randall and Graham and I did recently
and Michael Shermer commented on it and
it was all essentially on the,
um,
the,
the hypothesis that the great extinction
that happened with the North American
land animals that happened somewhere
around the end of the ice age and,
um,
the end of the ice age,
the abrupt end of the ice age being
caused.
Please correct me if I fuck this up
being caused by a comet impact.
Um,
Michael Shermer had some questions about
that and we said this would be an
amazing podcast to get everybody
together in a room and go over this.
Since then,
there's been some interesting stuff
that's happened.
What I thought,
this is really fascinating that Forbes
has a mainstream article in Forbes,
did a comment wipe out ice age
megafauna,
and this is actually from just a couple
of weeks ago,
and then there was also this
interpretation that's fairly recent as
well,
about one of the stone tablets,
uh,
one of the stone carvings rather on go
Beckley,
tempe and gram.
You would probably be the best to
describe that.
Yeah,
that was published in Mediterranean
Mediterranean archeology and archeometry
Peer Review Journal by a couple of
scientists from the University of
Edinburgh.
And they are proposing an interpretation
of the.
Go back to the TAPI imagery.
There's quite a lot of imagery on those
t shaped pillars,
particularly one pillar,
pillar 43 and enclosure d and uh,
their deduction,
what they take from their
interpretation.
Of course,
many will disagree with them.
Their interpretation is that those,
uh,
those images are speaking of the comet
impact there.
Speaking of a comment that hit the earth
roughly 12,000,
900 years before our time,
and Randall,
this has been something that you have
been obsessed with for many,
many years now.
We've documented it and detailed in many
in many conversations that we've had on
the podcast.
Oh yes.
No,
I,
I can't say that I'm that familiar with
that article.
I haven't had a chance to get into it,
but this idea that the common impact is
the what,
what has caused the end of the ice age.
Well,
it's so complex,
but now what we do is we throw or some
type of an impact into the mix and it
seems to fill gaps that have pulled this
right up to you.
It seems to fill gaps that were
at this point still unexplained.
Um,
you know,
there's varying theories between some
extent of climate change in some extent,
of human predation that caused the
extinction.
And I've always felt like you can't
blame it on one or the other.
I think humans probably had a role but
only in the very final stages of the
extinction event.
And one of the,
um,
one of the scenarios would certainly
suggest that there were extreme climate
changes between the bought what's called
the Bowling Alley Rod,
which was the rather gradual warming at
the very end of the pleistocene.
Which was then followed by the younger
dryas,
which was the return to full glacial
cold and in the end of the younger
Dryas,
which is dated at about 11,600,
which is considered now to be the,
the boundary of the Holocene Post,
a younger dryas pre boreal,
it's called would be the beginning of
the Holocene and it seems that most of
the extinctions did occur between
roughly 13,000 and 11,600 years ago.
Although the dating has a widespread on
it,
so you can't pinpoint it down to a
specific event.
But I've always felt like that there had
to be something we needed to look at
that triggered the extreme climate
changes that we do see at the end of the
ice age.
Um,
and to my opinion,
you can't,
um,
attribute that solely to milankovitch
theories,
which is basically the changing solar
terrestrial geometries because there are
too slow in what we see at the end of
the ice age were very rapid climate
changes.
And so one of the things that I think
has been missing has been the trigger.
Wallace brecker pointed out,
or a years ago that possibly a major
flood from the draining of Lake Agassi
caused an interruption of the thermo
Halian Circulation,
which is the basically the circulation
of the North Atlantic Ocean and that
this might have been what triggered the
younger dryas and then also contributed
to the mass extinction events,
but now I think that the dating of the
draining of Lake Agassi is too late for
that and was probably a ladder event
within the overall melting phenomena
that occurred between roughly 14,600 and
about 11,000 years ago.
Somewhere in there we have to fit that
mass extinction event.
And,
and I definitely have thought that
climate change was the dominant factor
in that,
but then what triggered the climate
change?
That always seemed to me to be something
that was not ever really explained.
Um,
the comment impact theory is very
controversial,
but the evidence has been steadily
mounting now for a decade,
including physical evidence,
renovate the core samples that show
nuclear glass.
I'm scattered out throughout Asia and
Europe that are roughly the same time
period when they do the core samples.
Yes,
it's most of it's dating to 12,000,
800 to 13,000 years ago.
These are called impact proxies.
Nano diamonds,
melt,
melt glass,
microsphere fuels.
These kinds of,
these kinds of things are associated
with impact,
not necessarily always caused by impact.
So this has been part of the reason for
the controversy,
but it's the abundance of all of these
at a particular level which leads a
large group of scientists to feel that
we have had a common impacting in the
partner.
That's the full assemblage of things
that it's difficult to explain
by processes without invoking some type
of a cosmic advance.
And it also corresponds with what you
believe is a period where earth travels
through a series of comments.
Well,
this
gets to,
to the,
to the ideas of the what would be called
the British Neo catastrophist Victor
Club and William Napier and,
and a number of others that have
theorized that from time to time earth
counters the debris from a large
disintegrating comet.
And there's an interesting,
uh,
William Napier addresses this and an
interesting article I can pull up here
pretty soon.
Um,
that possibly around 13,000 years ago,
earth may have encountered some of the
debris from a disintegrating comment,
which ultimately goes back to a fred
whipple who was one of the godfathers
of,
of commentary.
It was just coming on that for a second.
I mean specifically build,
build Api,
invicta clue bar are identifying the
remnants of this comment,
a width of the Taurid meteor stream,
which is familiar I think to everybody.
We pass through it twice a year.
We see meteoroids particularly at end of
October,
early November,
that Deb restream is still there.
It still contains,
according to their argument,
bits of the comment,
there are large objects in it like
commenting and key read,
nicheology auto and so on,
four or five kilometers in diameter.
And the suggestion is that the media
stream has got lots of small bits of
dust,
but it's got some larger stuff too.
And some of that stuff fell out of the
media stream 12,800 years ago and
impacted primarily the North American
ice cap.
Now,
my goal,
when you listened to that podcast,
you had some questions.
You are professional skeptics.
So of course you were skeptical.
What are your thoughts about all that?
Uh,
yeah,
let me pull it back and it gave her a
bigger picture.
After the podcast I went and got the
book magicians of the Gods and uh,
and actually I listened to it on audio,
so it's,
I don't know,
like 16,
18 hours of,
of Graham reading with his,
his wonderful British accent,
which is,
you know,
for Americans that elevates the quality
of the argument by an order of
magnitude.
Yeah.
That's how they sell things in
infomercials over there.
And uh,
and Graham,
you're a good writer.
It's a very compelling story to you.
You're a great skeptic.
And,
and,
um,
you know,
and so I think a number of points about
in general,
the idea of alternative archeology,
which is really what we're talking about
here.
I prefer that to pseudo archeology
because that's a little bit of it is
supposed to be a little bit of an
insult.
So alternative archeology it.
So it's good to remember that.
So you have these guys on the podcast
for three or four hours and the audience
listening thinks,
yeah,
why not these guys get a fair hearing.
I mean it's like there's the mainstream
and then there's these guys,
right?
But,
but there isn't just these guys,
there's hundreds of alternative
archeological theories.
So which one gets the play,
which one gets attention,
which one doesn't?
And for a mainstream archeologist who's
busy in the field and trying to get
grants and so on,
they mostly just don't have the time to
sort through all these alternative
theories because this is just one.
And as we'll see in the next couple of
hours,
there's hundreds and hundreds of things
to be addressed.
So that's kind of what we do.
Um,
so just to rattle off a few of the lost
tribes of Israel,
who Connell colonize the Americas Mormon
archeology,
explanation of native Americans,
the Kensington Rune stones in Minnesota
that the vikings had come here.
The black Egyptian hypothesis.
When I was in graduate school,
this book called Black Athena was
published at the Egyptians were actually
black and that the sort of western white
male dominance of history had written
them out of the path.
So,
you know,
this was a whole alternative history,
alternative archeology,
piltdown man,
Thor Heyerdahl and his hypothesis that
the Polynesian islands were colonized by
South Americans who went west to east to
west.
That's since been debunked,
but that,
that's yet another one of these things.
South American archeology,
Omac statues seemed to have like African
features on them,
so maybe Africans went directly across
to South America.
So there's,
you know,
Eric Van Donican securize stitching now
most of these Graham a rejects and in
his book too,
to your credit.
So you're a good skeptic too.
Uh,
but,
but for,
for an outsider to an anthropologist
from Mars who steps into this thing,
cold doesn't know anything,
it's like,
well,
they're all alternative,
which is the right one.
And how do we know?
And so what was the way it works in
sciences is the default position is the
skeptical position.
We assume your hypothesis is not true.
Not,
not just you,
anybody's hypothesis like the,
uh,
the clue,
nate napier hypothesis that was widely
published.
It was widely covered in mainstream
scientific journals and popular science
magazines like scientific American and
it has not fared that well over the last
decade or so.
It's still around,
it's still debated but that.
So you put it into the mainstream
through peer review journals and then
you go to conferences and you have it
out and,
and that's kind of where we end up with,
well this is what we think is probably
true for now.
And then all these other people out
here,
if they don't jump in and into the pool
where everybody is,
then there's no way for an outsider to
know whether these alternative things
have any validity or not other than they
make a compelling case in a popular
book.
Yes.
But,
but what are the mainstream scientists
think?
So,
and the problem is,
is that,
so a couple of specific things like when
I call patternicity,
the tendency to find meaningful patterns
in random noise.
You know,
the Virgin Mary on a grilled cheese
sandwich or whatever.
Those are fun examples,
but you know,
taking like a pictographs,
peck,
peck the glyphs and then comparing them
to constellations like,
you know,
here we have some constellations on your
roof here.
It,
it's easy in the mind's eye to find a
pattern.
The question is,
did those people really think 10,000
years ago,
5,000 years.
So this is a field called archeo
astronomy ed crop or the director of the
Griffith Observatory here in La.
This is what he does.
And sometimes the pattern,
he thinks the patterns mean something.
Sometimes they're totally random
and uh,
or you take something like the pyramids,
you know,
as,
as Graham knows,
there's 100 theories about the pyramids
and there's the mainstream one.
And then there's all these other ones.
And this is why people like the director
there,
he just can't deal with them all,
you know.
So just as one example I used in my
book,
white people eat were things that,
you know,
one guy calculated that if you divide
the height of the pyramid to twice the
size of the base,
you get the number close to Pi.
And then he just sorta works all these
different numbers,
so therefore it's cosmically
significant.
Well Richard Hoagland was like the best
example of what would find these
patterns in Mars and the like in claim
that like if you go from this rock to
half the distance and like why would you
do that?
Like that doesn't make any sense.
He would create these patterns.
Right?
And that's okay.
I mean all scientists look for patterns,
so like to take climate change,
either the earth is getting warmer,
it's not either it's human caused or
it's not.
There's a pattern in the data.
You can see the pattern.
The question is,
is the pattern real?
So this is why we call it,
we used the term climate consensus.
It's not a democracy,
it's not like we voted on it and decided
this is the truth.
It's that independently.
All these different scientists working
in different fields,
publishing in different journals come to
the same conclusion.
So we call this conciliate science or
convergence of evidence science that
it's not like these guys are meeting on
the weekends going,
boy,
we got to combat those.
You know,
those crazy right wingers with our data
there independently coming to these
conclusions.
So that lifts our confidence that,
yeah,
there's probably something to their
theory such that there's now so much
data converting to this,
you'd have to deconstruct every one of
those independent lines.
Um,
so then you have things like,
um,
what I call the problem of the residue
of anomalies in any field,
there are residue of anomalies we can't
explain.
So like [inaudible] for example,
a Ufo ologists me,
a skeptic agree that 90 to 95 percent of
all the Ufo sightings are explained by
natural phenomenon.
Venus swamp gas airplanes piece,
whatever.
They know that.
And so we're really only talking about
five percent.
Like how do you explain that one right
there in 1967 on June third,
and yet I don't know.
No one knows that one.
And then from there they build.
Well,
that's my case.
Then if you can explain that,
then I,
I have a kate.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
that's very different than what we're
talking about here is how is that
relevant.
It's totally relevant because I think
almost all of your argument is based on
this residue of anomalies,
uh,
what we call the god of the gaps
argument.
If you scientists can't explain,
you know,
this particular rock right here or that
particular Petroglyph,
and I'm going to count that toward my
compilation of data to support my
hypothesis of a lost civilization.
No one is saying that the scientists can
explain it.
What would essentially,
particularly Randall with a series of
images as shown is that what you have
here is something that can be explained
by rapid,
rapid melting of the ice caps and
Randall stepping on fuel.
I'll just go ahead and.
Well,
they do say it depends what you mean by
rapid glacial.
Damn.
That is our geologists will tell us that
moment that,
that breaks.
That's fairly rapid.
Back in [inaudible] 96,
it was a very popular book called,
uh,
Noah's flood.
This was a serious book by two
geologists that said it was the rapid
filling up at the black seat that
swamped over the civilizations living on
the edges of this and that.
That's where the wacky and flood story
comes from,
so it was widely debated and so on and
sense.
It hasn't fared that well,
but that's fairly rapid.
I mean we're talking over the course of
weeks or months or years to a geologist,
you know,
thousands of years is rapid,
so impact by a comment and it happens in
a couple of hours or a couple of days or
weeks versus a couple of months or
years.
What do we mean by rapid?
Okay,
well,
what are you saying then?
Okay,
so what are you saying about their
theories in particular?
Okay,
so the problem,
I think,
Graham,
that the deepest problem is,
is how much of your theory depends on
negative evidence.
That is,
I don't accept the mainstream
explanation for the pyramids,
the Sphinx,
the Machu Picchu,
whatever.
Let's not talk about that.
Let's just talk about this specific
subject because it's going to take a
long time just to cover yet.
Alright,
so my final point is,
is the falsifiability one.
That is,
what would it take to refute your
hypothesis?
Like for me,
the answer would be like if go,
go,
Beckley,
Tepi turned out to be what you think it
might've been
the place where advanced ancient
civilization once inhabited,
or they used it.
Where are the metal tools?
Where are the writing the,
the examples of writing?
Perhaps the decision was made not to use
metal.
Perhaps a decision was made that arrows
had taken place that,
that in reinventing civilization,
we shouldn't perhaps go down quite the
same route as before.
Perhaps writing isn't always an advance.
Perhaps perhaps,
uh,
an oral tradition which,
which records in memory which enhances
and uses the power of memory may be a
very effective way of,
of,
of dealing with information.
We regard writing as a,
as an advance,
and I can see lots of reasons why it
isn't advanced,
but if we put our self into the heads of
ancient peoples,
maybe it wasn't.
I mean there's a tradition from ancient
Egypt that the god,
both God of wisdom was the inventor of
writing.
But we have,
we have a text in which he is.
He is questioned by a pharaoh who is,
who is saying,
well actually have you really done a
good thing by introducing writing
because then the words may roam around
the world without wise advice to,
to put them into,
into context and what will happen to
memory when people do so.
So there might be a choice not to not go
that way,
but,
but then what do you mean by advanced
when you say there used to be a lost
advanced civilization before 10,000
years ago,
but let's just wait for a second because
what we know for a fact is that the
carbon dating in all the area around
Beckley,
Tapi is somewhere around 12,000 years.
Is that correct?
Eleven thousand 600 years ago because
the earliest they found so far,
but a great deal of Rebecca Tapi is
still underground.
Right?
So it,
at least what we know is someone built
some pretty impressive structures
11,000,
600 years ago,
7,000 years before stone when that story
broke.
This is long before you came along with
your book.
Uh,
it was controversial in the sense that
we thought hunter gatherers could not do
something like this because to do that
you need a large population with a
division of labor and so forth.
And so what the response to
archeologists was,
well,
I guess we were wrong about hunter
gatherers.
Maybe they can do more stuff than we
gave them credit for.
So why is that not a reasonable
hypothesis versus they were,
it was actually a band,
but we mean something completely
different by advanced,
not rioting and metal and technology.
We mean,
I don't know what you mean.
What do you mean?
Well,
I mean we have,
we have a body of archeology which goes
on for decades,
which is saying that a megalithic sites,
for example,
giganteum in Malta or Hydra,
Hydra megalithic sites a date to no
older than five and a half to 6,000
years old gig.
Tia would push it close to 6,000 years
old and they're no oldest sites than
that.
And therefore the Megalithic site is
associated with a certain stage of
Neolithic development.
Then along comes go,
Beckley Tepi 7,000 years older than
stonehenge.
Incredibly sophisticated site,
very large scale.
I mean Klaus Schmidt,
sadly he's passed away.
I spent three days working the site with
him.
He was very generous to me.
He showed me a lot.
He talked to me a lot and he said
basically 50 times as much as they've
already excavated is still is still
under the ground that there's hundreds
and hundreds of giant stone pillars that
they've identified with ground
penetrating radar.
He's not even sure if they're ever,
if they're ever going to excavate them,
but by all accounts we are looking.
If we take what still under the ground
into account,
we're looking at the largest megalithic
site that's ever been created on earth
and it pops up
11,600 years ago with no obvious
background to it.
It just comes out of nowhere.
No,
to me,
that's rather well that we know of,
but to me that says that's immediately a
rather puzzling and interesting
situation and I would be remiss as as an
author and an inquire into these matters
if I didn't take great interest in that.
The sudden appearance,
7,000 years before Stonehenge,
you have a megalithic site that dwarfs
stonehenge.
To me,
that's a mystery and it's really worth
inquiring into.
We love to put it into
perspective.
That's more than 2000 years older than
what we now consider to be the building
of the Great Pyramid of Giza in
comparison to us to then so between our
time now in 2017 in the construction,
the great pyramid,
you're talking about 2000 years earlier
than that and that is unbelievable when
you're talking about 7,000 years before
what we thought people were doing.
Okay,
but my point was that instead of before
we go down the road of constructing a
lost civilization that was super
advanced,
but different from our idea of advance,
why not just attribute to these fully
modern hunter gatherers who had the same
size brains we have and so on that they
were able to figure out and do this.
We just under estimated their ability.
So why did archeologists tell us for so
long?
Hunter gatherers couldn't do it,
and we needed agricultural populations
that could generate surpluses that could
pay for the specialist
theory,
but that was it.
So now with archeologists are saying,
well,
I guess we were wrong about hunter
gatherers.
Well,
they might be wrong about hunter
gatherers or there might be another
civilization that they had not
discovered that has been unearthed by
the doctor.
Lost civilizations are not such an
extraordinary idea.
I mean,
nobody knew that the Indus Valley
civilization existed at all until some
railway work was done around Ninja
Teodoro in 1923.
Suddenly a whole civilization pops up
out of the woodwork.
There's just never been taken into
account before.
The 19 twenties.
We still can't read it.
Script,
you know,
the.
The idea that we,
that we come across that another turn of
the spade reveals information that
causes us to reconsider.
Not just was it hunter gatherers or
agriculturalist,
but perhaps something bigger than this
is involved.
That's not,
that's not such an extraordinary idea.
I get it that mainstream archeology
doesn't want to go there,
but that's my job to go.
I don't think that that's correct.
They would be happy to go there if
there's evidence for it by what you just
said.
They now fully accept the Indus Valley
civilizations.
How did that happen?
If they were dogmatically?
Closed minded and
I don't say that they were dogmatically.
Closed minded about that.
The evidence,
the massive amount of evidence that came
up with the discovery of Mahindra,
Daro,
harappa dollar Veera and other and other
such sides.
It's very difficult.
You have to be completely stupid to say
that that's not a civilization.
Got Beckley tap is a bit more nuanced.
You know,
we have stone,
we have stone circles.
We have some interesting astronomical
alignment.
Is the world's first perfectly north
south allied building maybe?
No,
definitely.
Again,
that's a patternicity thing.
Deciding Klaus Schmidt,
well,
that's all right,
but any of us who read back into
10,000 years ago what we're thinking
that they might have been thinking,
that's always a dangerous for anybody,
not just you all.
That's a good point.
Who Klaus Schmidt classmate was the
original excavator Africa,
basically tapping.
He was the head of the German
archeological institute,
dig,
add to go back to tempe.
He kindly spent three days showing me,
uh,
around the site and really nobody's
disputing the astronomical alignment,
so I've got back to the me.
They weren't particularly interesting to
Klaus Schmidt,
but they're there.
And what is the alignment like?
How is it established when you have a
perfectly north side,
north,
south aligned structure,
perfectly north,
south to true north,
not magnetic north.
Then you are dealing with astronomy by
definition and there are other
alignments of the certain struggles as
established today or with the procession
of the equinox.
It's the rotation axis of our planet.
Okay,
so it to this day,
it points exactly in the same place
where it was pointing to the true north,
but back to the know they don't want to
go.
Sure.
They want to go there.
They would happy,
be happy to go there.
Case in point,
two weeks ago in the journal Nature,
the most prestigious scientific journal
in the world,
there was published an article that
humans are maybe neanderthals lived in
San Diego area 130,000 years ago.
This is an order of magnitude older than
the clovis date.
This was the mastodon bones.
They found that balance yet.
So here's an example of how.
Okay,
so clearly there's not some conspiracy
to keep alternative people are fringe or
or radical theories out.
It was published in peer reviewed the
most prestigious journal in the world.
There it is.
Time bad.
What happened?
Well,
it hasn't been a massive reaction to
that and lots of.
Lots of scathing remarks,
either academics,
but that's normal.
That's how science works.
You get,
you get pushed back.
It's.
You got to have a thick skin.
It's just the way it goes.
Got to have a thick skin,
that's for sure,
but maybe sometimes your skin is so
thick that you can't sense anything
around.
Of course we don't want that either.
So what do you think is going on when
you look at something like directly,
Beckley tappy that's covered,
covered up purposefully,
right?
Deliberately buried.
Again,
I say Klaus Schmidt,
he,
he's the authority on this.
He's the excavator.
He absolutely adamantly insisted that
that site was deliberately buried and
finally covered with a hill,
which is what got badly tappy means in
the Turkish language.
Potbellied hill.
Yep.
And you're talking about something,
give me the perspective of how large
they believe it is currently as of
current.
What's excavated at the moment is on a
scale of Stonehenge,
what's under the ground?
Maybe as much as 50 times larger Jesus,
but.
But it got back the template there.
No one lived there.
There's no tools.
There's no.
Well,
you're talking about $12,000,
but if it's buried,
it should be.
It should be pottery.
There's no pottery,
no writing,
no articles of clothing.
No one lived there when you're saying
nobody lived there,
so why should they have poetry?
Why should pottery beat in the field?
But why were they glad they go along and
breaks and pots and stick it in the
artificial their trash when they see
something that would indicate it's
different.
A different kinds of people than what
we're used to seeing in the
archaeological record can alert rubbish
that they poured in.
It's just stones in earth buckets of it.
In other words,
grant for you to gain support for your
theory amongst mainstream
archaeologists,
they want to see positive evidence to
overturn the old theory.
In other words,
the burden of proof is on the person
challenging the mainstream in every
field,
but isn't there some proof that the
mainstream idea of these hunters and
gatherers never had anything in what the
theory was that would indicate these
people were capable of building
something you remotely the size of
Beckley tend?
To me,
that's the stunning beauty of this find.
It overturns ideas of primitive hunter
gatherers.
It could not do this.
Apparently they can.
That's one.
Yeah,
assessor.
Right?
So this.
I call this somebody else.
The bigotry of low expectations.
You know,
it's like we had this kind of low
expectations for these hunter gatherers.
Maybe we should jettison that idea.
And in my own other field of the history
of religion,
it also threw that off because this
apparently was a kind of a spiritual
religious.
That's the wrong word.
They would have used.
Actually nobody can.
Nobody can know that that's right.
So,
but if it was,
this is the big national geographic
article,
emphasize that maybe this is the very
first religious spiritual temple ever
built because they didn't live there.
So they went there for a reason.
It also possible that this is signs that
civilization was more advanced 12,000
years ago.
Then we thought,
okay,
more advanced.
What again?
What do we mean by talking about the
ability to construct and amazing
structural.
How big was it?
Like how tall were these?
Some of them are 20 feet tool.
Yeah.
But some of them are smaller with,
with,
with uh,
astronomical alignments clashed.
Smith called it a center of innovation.
He was intrigued by the way that
agriculture emerges around go Beckley
Tepi at the same time that go back to
the tempe is created.
I mean,
he went on record with me.
Perhaps he's not right,
but he went on record with me as saying
that was the first agriculture.
These were the people who invented
agriculture.
Now to me,
the notion that a group of hunter
gatherers wake up one morning and invent
megalithic architecture,
the world's largest megalithic site,
and at the same moment invent
agriculture stretches credulity a bit.
And I think I would prefer to propose,
and I have proposed that what we're
looking at is evidence of some kind of
transfer of technology that people came
into that area who had other knowledge,
but that was applied and perhaps they
mobilize the local population around
this site.
Perhaps that's precisely why we see
agriculture developing there.
So perhaps that's the skill that's being
passed on,
but I don't see anything particularly.
Okay.
That stone work is spectacular,
but that's not any more advanced than a
few centuries millennium afterwards when
you're talking about something 20 feet
of stone that were hunter gatherers,
couple hundred people can move multi ton
stones.
There's no mystery.
And moving the stones.
I started moving 20 ton stones in
Indonesia today.
That culture still exists.
We.
You also know that the carving on the
outside is extremely complex.
It's three dimensional carving.
Okay.
But you know,
that means that loud.
Do you know what that means?
That lascaux at 30,000 ago has
magnificent cave paintings with three
dimension that animals.
But that's painting,
you know,
that they.
Hold on a second.
Do you know what I'm saying?
When I say three dimensional carvings
and like the Venus de Milo carvings were
on the outside,
meaning they didn't carve them into the
rock,
they carved away the rock around them,
which is pretty sophisticated stuff for
hunter gatherers and they're doing this
on these 20 foot tall stone columns.
I mean,
it's pretty impressive stuff.
Okay,
but there,
the assumption is that they couldn't
have figured this out.
We know from modern societies where,
say Australian aborigines in one
generation,
they go from stone tools to fly in
airplanes.
The brains are quite capable of doing
these amazing things.
Stones,
airplanes.
Without somebody introducing them to
Yeah.
You,
you're actually making his argument for
them.
No,
no.
It's not that much of a reach to carve
stone.
People have been carving stones,
but the tire archeological opinion on
megalithic sites for decades before this
was precisely that.
It was beyond their ability to attend
and now that mainstream has changed.
It's okay,
but let's start.
At the very least,
they will shift.
Let's pause for a moment.
So for sure.
We all agree human beings made this.
Yes,
not even so the aliens,
so the argument is not whether or not
aliens made it.
The argument is whether or not humans
made it,
that we're sophisticated.
Well,
there clearly sophisticated enough to
make this incredible structure that is
is some sign of some sort of
civilization.
I believe so,
yeah,
it is.
It's a gigantic structure.
I agree with grand that we again,
undersold who these people were.
My friend jared diamond goes to Papa New
Guinea.
He talks at the opening chapter of guns,
germs and steel.
How smart these people are that live out
there in nature and what it takes to
survive.
Sure.
He wouldn't last an hour from La.
He wouldn't last an hour with his pop
into Gideon friends out there in the
wild because he doesn't know how to
survive and they've been passing down
the information for generation after
generation.
Very smart.
Okay,
so it's not a problem of intelligence.
And is there a.
okay.
So here's the other thing we don't know
is that there might be lots more of
these sites and where there's the jar I
visited,
one of them are rotten Teppei you've
got,
you've got the t shaped pillows sticking
out the side of a hill and the farmers
back yard.
I mean,
I think we're actually at the beginning
of opening up this inquiry.
Not at the end of it,
but then it'd be before you.
Okay.
Why not just say we don't know.
This is a spectacular mystery and leave
it at that,
right?
Why write a book we're gonna.
Fill in all the gaps on the mainstream
side.
Won't speculate.
I'm willing to explore.
I don't claim to be an archeologist.
I'm not a scientist.
I'm an author.
It's my job to offer it a little
tentative point of view and to offer a
coherently argued alternative point of
view.
And I must say go back.
He strikes me as a gigantic fucking
mystery and a mystery that is worthy of
exploration from
a point of view that may not satisfy you
a well,
it doesn't.
You don't have to satisfy me,
you and your,
you and your colleagues and I don't,
I don't,
I certainly don't have to satisfy you or
them.
That's not my project.
Your opening chapter with Schmidt.
I thought I really love the kind of
conversational style you had with
Schmidt in the book where he's
dialoguing,
where she goes,
look at this and then he says,
but,
but wait,
what's that again?
Now he's a little bit like Columbia,
like,
wait,
wait.
I have just one more quick.
Just one more question.
And you know that ministry kind of
thickens.
That's perfectly okay.
That's great.
I mean that's what science is all about
is uncovering mysteries that we then
have to figure out.
So there's always more mysteries,
but that doesn't mean that's not
positive evidence in favor of a
particular theory,
like a lost civilization.
It's just we can't explain this full
stop.
Yeah,
we certainly can't explain it.
And you can explain it by saying that we
underestimated hunter and gatherers
either.
Well,
why not?
We know they made it.
Whatever you want to call them.
Well,
we know humans made it.
That's right.
We know humans made then whenever you
want to cry,
but why do they believe that people were
only hunters and gatherers 12,000 years
ago?
It's because they didn't have any
evidence.
The contract.
This is evidence to the contrary.
I agree.
So you agree that there weren't
harboring hunter and gatherers?
Okay.
But there's several stages in between
just 12 people living out in the jungle
by themselves versus us.
You know,
there's a whole bunch of different.
I would say that go Beckley.
Tapi is a gigantic stage.
While we don't.
They didn't live there,
so we have to figure out what,
where,
where were they living in,
what was there so that that has to be
excavated.
Well,
the only excavated a 10 percent.
Meanwhile what you're saying is that we
shouldn't speculate at all because I
mean mainstream archeology,
speculating,
speculating when saying it's definitely
was hunter gatherers who did this.
That's also a speculation.
Okay.
But not.
They may be more than hunter gatherers.
They may have been partially settled.
There's,
you can have any kind of number of
states,
but what you can't apparently have is
the possibility of a transfer of
technology from people who are really
masters of that technology already when
they came in,
but where are these people?
Whereas when you're dealing with 12,000
years ago,
now let's find their homes.
I don't know.
I don't know that that Holmes matter.
Would their homes even survive after
$12,000?
I'm not sure
there's something.
Well,
what trash and tools we've got.
Go back to the top.
It confronts us.
It challenges the mainstream model.
I think it's reasonable to consider the
possibility that there was something
more than just hunter gatherer is
involved here in creating this
extraordinary place and that's all I've
done.
It seems to me that to say hunter
gatherers could build this.
I'm not.
I wouldn't be opposed to the idea that
they're hunting and gathering,
but it does certainly imply a lot of
leisure time.
Yes,
a lot of leisure time.
Well,
we know 100 yet.
Oh,
sorry.
It's okay.
It was like,
well,
again,
if we place this back,
particularly within that climate zone at
11,006
to 12,000,
13,000 years ago,
whatever it turns out to be,
we're dealing with an extremely
demanding and challenging climate,
which,
which wouldn't necessarily,
to my mind be conducive to the emergence
of a settled culture that would be
capable of undertaking a project on this
scale.
And as somebody who's built a lot of
things and move quite a few heavyweights
in my time,
um,
I find it the idea sort of perplexing to
me that they would be what I,
what I would have to ask is what is
their motive?
What is their motive for undertaking a
project on this scale?
Because it's an enormous project and to
move a 20 ton block of stone is really a
challenging task to undertake today,
today.
Well without,
without,
you know,
uh,
the infrastructure of,
of,
of large machines and so forth.
But to do it by hand,
it would be an enormous undertaking.
And,
and I,
you know,
to me it's like when are they having
time to hunt and gather when you're
engaged in a project of this scale,
but we know hunter gatherers have way
more free time than modern society
people do.
That's the one thing we've learned is
that it's a pretty good way to make a
living.
Actually,
they have a better varied diet than we
have.
This is the,
you know,
the Neanderthal Diet,
right?
They have a better varied diet and a lot
more free time.
Yeah,
but that's a lot less stress.
We knew that all along about hunter
gatherer is when we were saying they
couldn't build megalithic sites,
but we're,
we're making time to do it where the
environment is undergoing rapid changes
to which adaptations would be extremely
challenging and we know those changes
are going on all over the planet.
We know that sea levels are rising
rapidly,
rising over a period of a few thousand
years from,
from a c stand low of about 400 feet up
to the present level.
We also know that that by Otis,
we're shifting dramatically all over the
planet.
The,
the,
the effects of the younger Dryas,
we're global pretty much that is I think
the emerging consensus now that that
both hemispheres north and south were
being affected by the climate changes or
the younger dryas.
So what we're doing is replacing this,
this phenomenon of this,
this project within this context of
these extremely challenging times in
which,
you know,
adaptation to the environmental changes
could easily be the,
the all consuming challenge of the
Times.
I'm just finding it difficult to imagine
a disconnect too,
to see this disconnect between a project
of this magnitude and the motive for
doing it during a time when obviously
the environment could be posing serious
constraints upon people's ability to
function in that random.
We don't even know the motives of the
Easter islanders and no,
we don't raise these huge state,
but we know they did it,
but as debt become a central question,
know what,
something to have motivated,
but then let's get back to tobacco.
Tempe,
so we.
So let's just be real clear.
We know that we're humans.
We know that it's at least 12,000 years
old and we know that the real dispute
here,
the real question is,
did these people have structures and did
they have agriculture?
We know that they were human beings.
They were essentially modern human
beings,
so or the hunter gatherers or did they
have structures in they didn't have
structures and they didn't have
agriculture.
I'm happy they did.
So the fact that they were able to build
something so monumental.
What kind of a leap is it at all to
think that these people could figure out
how to plant food and figure out how to
make a house?
Well,
I mean,
again,
if you look back 30,000 years,
40,000 years to these cave paintings,
these are pretty sophisticated,
beautiful.
They are clearly.
They had abstract reasoning.
They could think from the concrete to
the abstract and so on.
It's not a big reach to go from that to
moving stones around.
Let's say there's a big difference
between painting and engraving on cave
walls and created
the largest megalithic site that's ever
been built on earth.
I think there's a huge difference
between those two.
I mean,
nobody would compare the construction
effort on on stonehenge or began tia
with cave paintings.
I agree with you.
The cave paintings are magnificent.
I've had the privilege to visit many of
the painted cave stunning work and as
Picasso said,
when he came out of Alaska,
we have invented nothing.
I mean they were.
The staff was that modern human mind,
symbolic mind at work there,
but this is another matter.
This is a large scale construction
project that's going on and it's not
just a construction person has like
huts.
It's hundreds and hundreds of very,
very large megalithic pillars which have
to be mobilized,
brought to the place,
you know,
organizing a workforce in order to do
that.
Even that requires preparation and time
and learning and practice.
It's not something that you wake up one
morning and just can do overnight.
You think that the paintings are more
impressive than go back?
Yeah.
Or at least comparable.
I think that's absolutely ridiculous to
convey
three dimensionality on a two d plane
that because Oh man.
It's like,
wow,
that's a crow.
It's like developing perspective and to
use the natural shape,
but it's not create a three dimensional
perspective.
Look is that's pretty abstract.
Comparing apples and pears.
It's not a construction project,
but I don't think it's even remotely.
What I'm saying is that it doesn't take
a huge leap of imagination to think
these people were pretty smart.
They were smart.
We know what they are smart.
Just because of the fact that those
construction projects were done by who?
By whoever.
We know that they were smart.
Whoever built go Beckley tap who was
clearly intelligent.
Whoever made those three d carvings,
clearly they were intelligent,
but to think that someone drawing on
cave paintings is more impressive.
20 foot stone columns with three
dimensional carvings on them have a lot
of animals that weren't even native to
the to the region.
That's not the case because they could
have been the Danimals,
but my point
though is that these paintings are like
say 30,
40,000 years old.
Took it back to the top so there's tens
of thousands of years to develop more
that we were very likely to find more
archaeological site up til now.
We haven't found that we haven't.
We haven't found all of that
intermediate material which is see if I,
if I could actually see that
intermediate material between the upper,
upper Paleolithic cave art and go back
to the top.
If I could see the gradual evolution and
development of skills,
I wouldn't need to invoke a lost
civilization.
The survivors of a lost civilization
who've mastered those skills elsewhere
to come in and teach those skills that
go badly,
Tevye,
but it still looks to me like a transfer
of technology,
unless you can show me that evolutionary
process whereby I can understand how
this group of hunter gatherers became
equipped to create this giant side where
they practiced,
where they learned the skill to move the
stones,
to organize the workforce to feed and
water the workforce in a rather dry
place.
All of that is actually quite a
logistical challenge.
Yup.
And obviously somebody met it somehow.
Some humans.
Yeah.
So the real question is,
do they have structures,
did they have agriculture,
did they have some sort of a community
where they lived on an established
location?
I would,
I would imagine so would that would push
back the time where we thought that
there was a civilization that would push
them back into a realm of at least stead
stepping out of the hunter gatherer
stage.
Now you're married as you show in your
book.
He did not go as far as you.
You're certainly not,
but he admitted it to mystery.
Okay.
Why?
That would be the scientific approach.
I don't know what it is.
Great mystery.
Let's just wait and see.
Versus a,
I'm going to populate a lot of
civilization.
Nothing wrong with that grant.
It's a free country.
And scientists do this all the time as,
as you've mentioned,
there's a rather humorous thing which I
have to say actually,
I might even ask Jamie to pull up the,
um,
the,
a couple of images of fingerprints of
the gods.
That's the book I'm best known for.
Uh,
and when I,
uh,
published fingerprints of the Gods in
1995,
essentially I was saying civilization is
much older and much more mysterious than
we thought and I was ridiculed for
proposing that 2013,
one of the magazines that ridiculed me,
New Scientist magazine in Britain,
publishers as a cover story picture of
go back to Tempe and the headline
civilization is much older and much more
mysterious than we thought.
Okay,
fair enough.
And,
and scientists do do this.
I mean,
I've followed paleoanthropology for my
whole adult life and one of the big
mysteries is how did we get a big brain?
How do we get to abstract reasoning
from,
from say what chimps can do.
No one knows the doubling of the human
brain size over a period of 2 million
years because no one knows every couple
of years there's a new book out.
It's climate change.
It was the throwing arm cooking,
cooking meat.
Meat is another big one.
A Harvard professor meet.
Okay.
And these books come and go and some of
them have legs,
some of them don't.
And it's just
the way it goes.
And it rears Terence Mckenna is pretty
obvious.
It was psychedelics.
Yeah,
that's terence.
Mckenna's began.
But that switch,
the brightness,
the old Julian Julian Jaynes cabral
mind,
not at all.
This is David Lewis Williams,
who's professor of anthropology at the
University of Witwatersrand in South
Africa.
His neuro psychological theory of Cave
Art,
all cute Austin Terence Mckenna and food
of the gods.
He won a brilliant thinker.
What a brilliant alternative thinker,
but David Lewis Williams at the
University of Witwatersrand had been
working on this problem since 1973,
and his.
His argument is that there are
remarkable similarities that we see in
rock and cave art all around the world
are explained that we're dealing with a
shamanistic art.
Shamanism involves altered states of
consciousness.
This is typical visions of altered
states of consciousness,
and it seems to have a company to great
leap forward in human behavior.
And you've covered this in your book.
I covered it in supernatural and natural
as did you know Richard Wrangham theory.
This is a highly regarded scientist at
Harvard.
So here's the meat eating guy that it's
taking me like cooking the protein.
That's what gives you the energy to
build a huge brain.
Alright,
so now this guy is starting with 10,
10 pluses on his side.
He's Harvard and already respected and
even so his book was like,
Eh,
probably a series of different events
and a bunch of different factors.
It could be a number of different
things.
So let's get away from go Beckley,
Tappi and ancient civilizations and
let's get back to the geological
evidence which randall urine expert at.
And this is one of the main things that
you had a dispute with and this is one
of the reasons why we got everybody
together.
Now,
what are,
what is your thoughts on what Randall
and Graham propose specifically randall,
who is much more on the geological side
of things?
Yeah.
Well this is why I brought in my phone a
friend,
a geologist.
So by way of background after your show,
I thought,
you know this,
let's give this a fair hearing.
This is what we do.
So this will be our cover story and
the summer issue comes out quarterly.
I hope that mark defense is going to be
doing some more work on the draft of his
article for you that is up online
because that article is full of bullshit
statements about me which are
demonstratively false,
so he's happy to.
I'm happy to engage with those
particular issues.
Well,
I'll have to put on my reading glasses.
Whatever articles online this has not
been published yet.
Claims it claims that it's a draft of
the article that will appear in the
Tucson 2017 edition of skeptic magazine.
So pull it up grandma and
grandma.
Go over for.
So we'll have mark on.
So here's
magicians of the gods.
By the way,
Michael,
I mean,
you say that you're here to,
you know,
to respectfully aim to get at the truth.
There is contract.
The lost civilization from.
Let me,
let me just get to the top of this.
Uh,
I've got it here.
Just bear with me a second.
So amongst the words in mark defense
article,
here's accusing me of jumping the
public.
He's saying that I'm public enemy number
one.
He's accusing me of arm waving.
I wait,
I do.
Whereby arms a pontificating.
Well,
my grandfather was a minister of the
church,
a little interest in peer reviewed
research claim that no academic would
debate.
That's utter bullshit.
I had a debate with Zahi Hawass.
He's a leading Egyptian Egyptologist
back in 2015.
There was not my fault that Zahi Hawass
walked out on that debate.
I can play the video if you like a
minute and half of Zahi Hawass lambasted
me and then walking out and refusing to
debate further.
So it's bullshit to say I don't debate
or I'm not willing to debate.
And finally he says that I'm conning
hellacious number of people into buying
his books.
Now,
how can we get any dialogue going when
somebody begins like that?
Ben,
would you like some further
bear with me because I just have to
scroll down and I don't have a mouse.
I don't have a mouse.
So Hancock and Carlson claimed,
uh,
several times the academic,
no academic would debate them.
Not True.
I'm a,
I'm accused of doing an about face,
uh,
since uh,
since fingerprints of the gods are my,
are my views not allowed to evolve with
new evidence?
Is that somehow a crime on my part?
Let me just finish then.
I'm a cheap shot,
you know,
he cites he sues Gomorrah.
Um,
and,
and accuses me of not real or not having
the scientific knowledge to issue deal
with issues of gravitation.
No,
it's true that hey,
Susan Amara,
who is a descendant of the inkers who
has worked 70 years on the mega list of
sexy woman whose father before him or
Fred or Gomorrah works 70 years.
It's true that he's got a way out.
Theory about gravitation thing is I
stated my booklet.
It's a way out theory of what I go on to
say quoted in the attack is that
however,
this isn't the part of his theory I'm
interested in where I feel he is solidly
persuasive,
is in his observations of the anomalous
character of the monuments of the ad,
these etc. Etc.
DiffErent.
Doesn't cite that.
He just presents me as buying what
tamara says.
I mean,
if that's the stanDard that you're going
to have in skeptic magazine,
you have a serious problem and then go
back to the top.
Uh,
he contends that got back to the is too
advanced to being completed by hunter
gatherers and must've been constructed
by a more advanced civilization.
Well,
no,
that's not what I say.
I say it was constructed by hunter
gatherers,
but that they were advised and supported
by people who had knowledge of this kind
of work beforehand.
Getting,
getting a.
Well,
I think it's very Different.
I'm not saying it was constructed by.
I'm saying that the,
that a group of people settled amongst
hunter gatherers and transferred some
skills for them.
He says that,
um,
he quotes me.
Hancock makes the following stunning
claim quote,
our ancestors are being initiated into
the secrets of metals and how to make
swords and knives.
I do not make that claim.
I'm reporting that this claim is made in
the book of enoch.
that is not my claim.
THen what else?
So you don't think that's the
explanation?
Well,
I'm being misrepresented by your author
here.
If he wants to represent me,
if he accuses me of cherry picking,
he shouldn't carry.
Pick my statements issued for
candidates.
Let's get it right.
It's on the internet.
Well,
here's a beautiful one he didn't know it
was online.
It was a beautiful one.
He cites klaus schmidt,
um,
on the,
on the character.
Actor schmidt makes a salient point
almost as if he anticipated hancock's
book,
quote,
fabulous or mythical creatures,
creatures such as centers or the sphinx
wing bulls are horses do not yet occur
in the iconography.
And therefore in the mythology of
prehistoric times,
they must be recognized as creations of
the high cultures which arose later.
Well,
bullshit bullshit bullshit.
You've just been talking about the
painted caves.
Go to show vacay.
If you will see a lion man holding
started.
Lion man carved out of,
carved out of mammoth ivory.
Go to go to show the bison man
straddling lion woman.
Her right arm is transferring a is
transit to transforming into a,
into the head of a lion.
so certainly these mythical creatures
did exist in the upper paleolithic.
And it's rubbish to say that they did.
And I mean,
how can I go on the teapot?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So he's,
he's taking issue with me because I
suggest that the vulture on pillar 43
and enclosure d a is representing the
teapot teapot as some of the
constellation of sagittarius and he goes
and gives us little things of uncle sam
and some other thing that he shows to
anybody can impose any image on,
on anything.
Well,
it's not my fault That a couple of
academics who didn't even talk to me and
had nothing whatsoever to do to me
published a major study in the.
I quoted again the mediterranean
archeology and archeometry a peer review
journal where they make precisely that
identification.
So at least I'm not alone,
uh,
at least there are.
There are peer reviewed credentials
scholars who also agree that that figure
is representing the teapot as tourism
within the constellation of sagittarius.
No reference to that,
um,
shocks,
opinions.
We're supposed to not go into the
minutia because they've already been
dismissed by a study by lyricists and
fathi are too far from it.
That study doesn't dismiss shock at all.
None of that study was done on the body
of the sphinx itself.
It was done in the valley and the sphinx
temples,
and by the way,
the dates are extremely troubling.
Some of them could push it as far as
3000,
600 bc that the work was done or as
early in some cases as 1000 bc.
I don't think that study proves anything
and,
and so on.
And so to clarify what you do believe
then so that we don't misrepresent you.
Uh,
so you don't think that the lost
civilization instructed them on the use
of metals?
I don't know.
I don't see evidence for that to go.
Would you put that in the book then?
I didn't put it in the book.
I was quoting the book of enoch.
It's a huge passage
on the,
on the book of enoch.
It's not me who's saying that is the
book of enoch the same?
I understand,
but why the contract require your
defense to do is to state that hancock
is citing the book of enoch.
He didn't do that.
That's,
that is,
uh,
what's the word?
Disingenuous.
Is that the polite word you guys use,
but
more than disingenuous.
It's a character assassination.
What the question is,
why would.
What's the context of including that in
your book?
I forget.
Well,
the cod,
the context is that actually I was.
I was criticizing zechariah section.
That's primarily what I was saying.
You don't think that a lot of
civilization instructed the people who
build go beckley tip on the use of
metals in tools.
I see no evidence for that.
I see.
Go back to the top.
I can't,
I can't go say they instructed them on
the use of metals and tools.
Unless I can find evidence for what did
they do?
We don't make generated agriculture.
They created a center of excellence
around which they,
who built called beckley epi.
The lost civilization that advise them
that you think happened.
What did they do if they,
they've come through a cataclysm,
their survivors few in number.
This is my scenario.
You don't have to accept it.
I'm sure you don't.
Uh,
they settle it amongst.
Take refuge amongst hunter gatherers.
I mean,
I don't know.
You're probably quite.
Have some survival skills.
I don't have many,
I mean if,
uh,
if we would have a comedy impact in the
world today,
which will take out all the
underpinnings of modern civilization,
uh,
I might go settle with hunter gatherer
is because they are the people who know
best how to live in that situation.
medical skills,
yeah,
because most had togethers,
but I might be able to transfer some of
my knowledge to them.
I might be able to,
I might have something that I could
transfer to them and I might have very
strong reasons why I might not choose to
transfer all of it.
but.
So in other words,
perhaps this is what happened.
Okay.
Maybe.
But how is that different from zachariah
citron that?
Well,
the aliens advised it.
it's,
I think it's massively different,
especially since zacharias stitching
versus aliens arriving here in 19
seventies.
Nasa technology,
weirdly,
he wrote his book in the 19 seventies.
I mean,
I don't,
uh,
I,
I don't go there.
I don't make that,
I don't make that suggestion.
I'm simply saying perhaps there's been a
forgotten episode in human history.
Perhaps its fingerprints are present at
a nUmber of sites around the world,
but perhaps the extremely defensive,
arrogant and patronizing attitude of
mainstream academia is stopping us from
considering that possibility and
therefore I campaign to get that
possibility considered and I try to do
so with as loud a voice as possible.
Well,
you're doing it,
man.
It doesn't disturb you that you mean you
run skeptic magazine and someone
publishes something like that.
If it means that goes against the whole
idea of critical thinking.
I mean,
it's misrepresenting his quotes.
It's misrepresenting his perspective,
his point of view.
It's,
it's really disingenuous.
This is one reason we're doing this so
we could get his butt.
Why would anybody write something like
that?
And why would you guys publish something
like that without checking the facts?
We are a.
This was not supposed to be posted
online.
One of the reason why it's online
though.
How does something get online to such a
person who will do that are useful
contributor to your side of the debate?
Uh,
well,
one of the reasons we're here is to get
your point of view.
Exactly right.
All right,
so you're saying that there's no
evidence that any law civilization
exists only the fingerprints of their,
their influence on later peoples we do
know existed.
I'm saying they're physical objects.
I say go back to the top is one of them.
I say the sphinx is another,
but see this is that argument from
either ignorance or personal.
Incredulity.
I don't accept the mainstream or I can't
think of how this pyramids could've been
built.
Therefore it was built by somebody else
through some other technology.
That's not what I'm saying.
So does postdating.
It just
thinks he's older.
Uh,
I do go with Robert Stokes argument on
the geology.
I'm also very interested in the
astronomy of the site.
And again,
I have slides that I could show on this
if we have,
if we have time you might want to get
into ed krups criticism of the orion
correlation then why he says it's up to
upside down.
I can talk to you about that.
You know,
we do.
I mean,
I know it had crept argument about that
and that was from the nineties I think.
What's your thoughts on robert chuck's
conclusion?
I don't,
that's not something I know much about,
but it's a huge factor because he knows
about shotgun,
he rejects it,
the basis of that paper and that paper
really doesn't date the sphinx.
It works with dating of large blocks in
the valley and the sphinx temple.
There's not a single sample taken from
this week.
Alright,
then who dated it,
who dated it liberates us,
and then why?
Why do mainstream archaeologists not
accept the older data for the sphinx and
the and the answer is because they have
a whole bunch of other evidence that
points to the date that they think your
answer is very to your question is very
simple.
Mock laner zahi hawass put it on record
back in 1992 when John Anthony West and
robert schoch first presented the
rainfall erosion evidence on the sphinx
and what later on hawaii's said is the
sphinx can't possibly be 12,000 plus
years old because there was no other
culture anywhere in the world that was
capable of creating large scale
monumental architecture like this.
Show me one other structure that's
capable of doing that.
Well,
they could say that in 1992,
michael,
but they can't say it in 2017,
not sensical beckley.
Tapis.
If you don't mind,
graham,
could you please,
for people.
So this could be a standalone thing.
People can understand what is the
argument about the sphinx,
the enclosure,
the spanx,
and dr robert schoch from boston
university who's a geologist.
What was his conclusion?
What shock is saying is that the sphinx
and the trench out of which the sphinx
is cut a bears the unmistakable evidence
of precipitation induced weathering,
weathering caused by exposure to a
substantial period of heavy rainfall.
And that is particularly pointed out in
the vertical fissures in the trench.
They see the sphinx itself has been
subject to so restoration over so
many years that is difficult for people
to even see the core body of the sphinx
today.
Uh,
but it's these,
you can see the vertical fissures even
down at the back of there.
That is,
that is what shock counts as rainfall,
precipitation induced weathering,
heavy rainfall,
which is selectively removing the softer
layers and leaving the harder layers in
place.
And the problem is we don't have that
rainfall in giza in Egypt four and a
half thousand years ago.
You have to go back much earlier to get
that rainfall as the suggestion.
So that's the suggestion by robert
charge independently.
Yes.
If your conclusion is totally
independently.
Yeah.
Shock disagrees With me on many things.
It wasn't as a matter of fact.
Uh,
and,
and I disagree with him on many things,
but I,
I think he's on the money on this.
So that alone would set back at least
that one.
I mean,
it's pretty much established that the
great pyramid of giza was constructed
about 2,500 bc.
Right?
There's absolutely no doubt that a huge
project went on at giza around $2,500.
So your argument involved the parent,
not that the whole thing was that much
older,
was that parts of it seem to have been
from an earlier civilization or at least
that civilization far far earlier than I
was.
I would say that the ground plan,
what we have at giza,
the basic layout of the site was
established in what the ancient
egyptians called zep tepi the first time
a astronomically and geologically I and
my colleagues suggest that the first
time can be dated to the period of about
12 and a half to 13,000 years ago,
that,
that that was when the site was laid out
because there's an intriguing
astronomical alignments of the great
pyramids to the belt of orion.
I know ed crop has a completely opposIte
view on this and have the great sphinx
to the constellation of leo rising
[inaudible] housing,
the sun on the equinox,
the astrological age of leo.
Again,
I have slides I can in that would align
with the geological evidence that robert
schoch complies with a geological
evidence.
They always eight years of age of leo,
pretty much exactly spans the younger
dryas as metro thing.
And so the only argument agaInst that at
the time was that there were no other
structures like that from 12,000 years.
Correct.
And then ben crump said that the,
that the orion correlation wasn't real.
Uh,
because it was upside down.
I do want to get into that now.
Well first,
that's not the only argument.
It's that,
okay,
if the sphinx is built or the layout for
the whole thing is built in say 10,
11,000 years ago and then,
and then the pyramids are built 2,500
bc.
What happened in between where all the
people that trash the places where they
lived,
styles
of construction but not dated in
between.
I would propose michael something like a
monastery,
which has a relatively small
archeological footprint,
is on the side.
I mean the idea of information,
knowledge and traditions lasting for
thousands of years within a religious
system shouldn't be too absurd to us.
I'm in judaism is dealing with ideas
that are already best part of 4,000
years old if we go back to the child
sees and so on and so forth.
So that's all I'm suggesting really
that,
that the idea is preserved,
maintained that the,
the survivors of on the site,
but something like a monastery,
which is,
which has got a very small archeological
footprint.
It is not high.
Perhaps.
Again,
one can only speculate and I think
there's a lot of speculation on the
archeological side to one can only
speculate,
perhaps having gone through a cataclysm,
perhaps they felt to blame for this
wrongly or rightly,
I mean there are many,
many traditions in which humanity's
behavior is implicated in the cataclysm
that takes place and perhaps they didn't
want to switch civilization on
completely right there.
Perhaps they perhaps they waited,
pass down the knowledge through
initiates enough was there to create a
mystery because it's undoubtedly a
mystery that the construction of the
great pyramids,
the first huge pyramids in Egypt
proceeded only really by the xhosa
pyramid at sakara.
That the construction of the great
pyramids is vastly superior to the
construction of the pyramids of the
fifth and sixth dynasty that follow it.
And that's a little bit counterintuitive
that we have this collapsed and skills
one would have expected it to get
better.
So it sounds like the work on the
pyramid started already with a level of
knowledge.
Yes,
but okay,
so here's,
here's,
I would think about that.
There's a lot of perhaps seeing and
maybes because big as well,
so you have a bunch of egyptologists and
archeologists who have been working on
this site for centuries.
This is one of the most ancient
mysteries and so on and so say,
let's say there's like 20 lines of
evidence that point to built roughly
around this time period here and then
you come on and say,
okay,
but there's this one anomaly of the rain
thing that in the there was only rain at
this time.
Now there's a huge gap.
You have one anomaly or line of evidence
here and like 20 here we're talking
about different structures,
so there's not a lot of evidence that
points to the sphinx being from a
particular time period.
Well,
he's saying like 12,000,
right?
I'm saying the rainfall evidence
suggests that by other evidence that
alignment,
that is alignment with the constellation
of leo housing,
the sun,
right?
Dawn,
on the spring equinox,
it's an equinox.
Your market.
Nobody would dispute that.
The age of digit.
Well,
no.
I mean,
if you make a monument pointing
perfectly joyous,
I've stood on the back of the sphinx at
dawn on the spring equinox,
and believe me,
I guess I could show a picture.
It's head lines up perfectly with the
risinG sun,
but no,
I don't think anybody even crop is
disputing that.
it's an equinox.
Your market.
Now here's the thing,
you're an ancient egyptian.
You're building an equinox.
Your market in 2,500 bc.
Do you know what constellation is?
Housing the son in two thousAnd 500 bc.
I haven't run a little program.
It's the constellation of taurus.
So.
So logically,
if you're creating an equitable and the
ancient egyptians Were not shy about
making images of balls,
plenty of them.
If you're making an equinox,
your marker in 2,500 bc reshoot,
create it in the form of a bull,
not in the form of a lion.
You know?
That's the.
That's the puzzling issue.
And yet we do have a time when a lion
constellation housed the sun at dawn on
the spring equinox,
and that is the period of the younger
dryas.
Okay.
I'd say that's a pretty big leap.
I know you say that and your colleagues
also that too,
and
so now and then we have a gap of about
five or 6,000 years where there's
nothing.
There's no real.
Yeah,
please do.
I'm going to refer back to several
articles that were published in the
eighties and nineties.
This one is from from nature,
early eighties,
late quaternary history of denial and
what it's discussing is the evidence
that there was a major shift in the in
the hydraulic regime of the nile river.
It says between 20,000 and 12,000 years
before present when timberline into
headwaters was lower vegetation cover
more opened in today.
The nile was a highly seasonal,
braided river which brought mixed course
and find sediments down to Egypt and
Sudan.
This cold dry interval had entered ended
by 12,500 years before present when
overflow from lake victoria and higher
rainfall in Ethiopia sent extraordinary
floods down the main aisle and those
floods had been documented to have been
120 feet above the modern flood plain of
denial.
Any civilization or whatever you want to
call it,
living along denial river at that time
would have had to abandoned whatever
they were doing there in the industry
regime.
This intensified hydraulic regime.
And it says,
it goes on to say it marked a
revolutionary change to continuous flow
with a superimposed flood peak.
So what happened is that there was a
major environmental change that occurred
right there around 12,000 to 12,000,
500 years.
The dating could be adjusted somewhat
since the early eighties,
but the point is made is that because of
a major hydrological change,
major vegetational cover change,
major environmental change,
this would've caused also in imposed
changes upon whatever culture was
existing ehr or living there at the
time.
Now,
what we have is in the aftermath of that
event,
we have basically the emergence of
desert,
which now would require serious
adaptation.
It's very likely to that these events,
uh,
could have also decimated the population
at the time leaving,
um,
basically no workforce.
And then over a period of two or three
or 4,000 years,
you find that,
that there is enough of a recovery that
these kinds of monumental structures can
be renewed.
Um,
but it's clear from this and a lot of
other studies studies in the eastern
mediterranean showing that there are sap
propel layers which is caused,
which is basically material that has
been washed in from the continental
surface that has not oxidized it.
HIs essentially become rotten and
carried in organic material,
carried in off of the continents by this
enhanced regime of,
of waterflow actually forcing so much
water that there was a freshwater lid on
the eastern mediterranean that,
uh,
caused a cessation in the,
the,
the circulation between the upper waters
and the lower waters,
reducing the amount of oxygen brought
down to the,
to the lower waters.
And so you had these layers of mud that
formed on the bottom of the
mediterranean that show this massive
influx of fresh water flowing off of,
out of denial and off of the,
the egyptian continent at this same
time.
So clearly the evidence shows that there
were major climatic changes that
occurred around this time.
It is not so speculative to,
to imagine that whoever,
whatever,
and we don't have to invoke any kind of
a super advanced civilization,
but whatever cultures were there that
were perhaps capable of carving blocks
of stone transporting blocks of stone as
they were at go back during this time
range would have been that their,
that their activity would have been
interrupted to the extent that it
might've taken millennia to,
to recover,
to get the,
get the labor force necessary to
undertake major monumental programs on
the giza plateau.
So,
so I think that if we assume this
gradual listic scenario,
yeah,
that's a fair question to ask were what
happened in that interval.
But if there is a major climatic
downturn and a major disruption of the
several patterns of whatever culture was
already there,
then you know,
now we might have an explanation why
there would be a gap,
especially if these events caused a,
uh,
a bottleneck in the population of the
area.
of course,
this is all speculative,
but it is not speculative to say that
there is multiple lines of evidence
suggesting these major even cataclysmic
changes that engulfed that part of the
world during that era,
so that could,
that could provide an explanation of why
there is a gap there.
Makes total sense.
Well,
it does it because does it not only if
you have to have this thing in
conjunction with 12,000 years ago in the
lost civilization,
if you just say that rain water erosion
on the sphinx,
it is not an explanation for the age and
that the traditional accepted age is
what we think it is.
Then there's no gap to fill.
Yeah,
so really we're talking about is we
have,
again,
lots of evidence here.
One anomaly here.
I really want the anomaly thing to
stick,
so I got to explain the gap.
The gap is explained by environmental
changes.
What is the.
What is the lots of evidence other than
a lot of assumptions.
It's babies.
It's actually,
can you cite me a single contemporary
instruction from the date that the
sphinx is supposed to have been made?
That refers to the swings.
I'm sorry.
Can you cite a single contemporary
inscription,
contemporary contemporary to the date
that egyptologists ascribed to the
sphinx in other ways during the reign of
[inaudible]?
Can you cite me a single inscription
that talks about the sphinx being built?
This is scott.
I don't.
I don't study this area.
I don't know.
Okay.
Well you can't because there is no such
inscription.
Okay.
Well,
so what one would have thought they
would.
Well maybe it's a giant project is 270
feet long,
is 70 feet high.
It's carved out of solid rock.
Nothing,
but you have no reference to toll in the
old kingdom.
You actually have to come down to the
new kingdom to get references to the
sphinx and inscriptions that.
But you've already said that the
pyramids were built at the time we think
they were built,
not thousands.
I would say that a great deal of work
was done on the pyramids at the time of
2,500 bc.
I think the ground plan was laid out and
we have like the step pyramid,
which is crude or not as well designed
as the other pyramids.
That's,
that's a transitional stage at that time
often argued to be a transitional stage.
have you been to the step?
I'm sure.
RigHt.
And you've been to giza though?
No,
I've never been to giza.
Oh dear.
Well,
will they do make a very different
impact?
I mean,
I've climbed the great pyramid five
times.
I mean,
you're dealing with something orders of
magnitude different in terms of what's
required.
I mean this thing weighs 6 million tons,
but it's 481 feet high.
It consists of two and a half million
individual blocks of stone.
It's aligned to true north within three
60th of a single degree.
I mean,
to compare that to zosyn,
uh,
is really not a valid comparison at all.
What's more interesting to me is the
radical decline that takes place in
pyramid building skills.
In the fifth and sixth titus,
he go to ou nasco,
the pepe go to tatiana sakara.
These are a shambles.
You can hardly even recognize them as a
payment.
What happened to all that knowledge
that's invested in the great pyramid?
Why does Egypt evolve so rapidly?
Uh,
what,
how do we explain this pristine,
amazing work that's done on the great
period?
Unless there's a legacy of knowledge
being attached to it.
So every archeologist,
Egypt,
egyptian archeologist and egyptian knows
everything you just said they didn't and
they don't accept any of the arguments.
Why not?
That's why I'm needed because somebody's
got to counter this.
Is it just that they're closed minded
and they follow a lot of us and they
never think for themselves.
You want to see a close mind,
I'll play you one and a half minute
videos out here,
wash,
refusing to debate with me,
but all of them,
every one of the egyptologist and
archeologist over the last two centuries
and so on,
they're all dogmatically,
closed minded and they can't see the
arguments declares you or is it?
They're not convinced by your argument.
They're not convinced by my argument.
They genuinely an absolutely believed
that their argument is right.
The notion that I'm proposing is
apparently so preposterous to them that
it isn't even worthy of consideration,
but it is worthy of insults and attacks
on me,
on my integrity or my decency as a human
being.
On my honesty.
All of those things get attacked,
you know,
because mainstream and that's fine.
I'm ready for that and that.
By the way,
I know that archaeologists academics
constantly attack each other all the
time.
I used to take this stuff personally,
but then when I see what they do to each
other,
the ravaging attack,
dogs are let loose on on any new idea.
I sometimes wish scientists would,
would actually look for what's good in a
new idea rather than what's bad,
but I get why they do it for that,
but in other integrated young graduate
student
working in that area could make a name
for himself by overturning a son was a
young graduate student at the university
of cardiff studying egyptology.
He got marked down in his degree because
he proposed the possibility that the
pyramids and the sphinx might be or
might have older origins.
He was impressed by my work.
It did him a lot of harm in his degree
and and if all this was true,
then eventually I'm announcing my point,
my point,
which is if you go against the
mainstream view,
your career does not progress as an ego.
I disagree.
I mean how many an example,
how is it that we know?
Anything that we know about each example
from Egypt tology of somebody who's gone
against the mainstream view and being
lauded for,
so doing well,
we don't believe everything about it
that we believe two centuries ago and
say napoleon's time.
Right?
How did that knowledge come about?
How did all the change that science
identity begins with sean polygon and
the deciphering of the rosetta stone?
How was he able to do that against the
mainstream?
There was no mainstream.
The mainstream has taken time to form
and it's a very solid now just all sing
from the same hymn book.
You'll find very little disagreement in
every field,
but somehow or another,
einstein managed to make an impact
because he turned out to be right.
Well,
I'm no einstein and I don't know if I'm
right,
but I'm going to continue to oppose that
mainstream.
Somebody has to earth.
That's a valid comparison.
Einstein and archeology take
paleoanthropology.
I mean it's a completely different field
now than a century ago.
How did that happen?
If no one ever accepts new ideas?
They do.
It happens all the time while they're
being forced to accept basically tempe
and that's a new idea that like,
you know,
what you were talking about things
taking a long time and what seems like a
long time to us is really a blink of the
eye and in terms of archeology,
we're in the middle of that were
essentially in the middle of that with
things like go beckley,
tappy with forbes publishing an article
about the younger dryas possibly being
impacted by comments and that being one
of the causes of mass extinction.
Right?
And when these are all mainstream ideas
and everyone alvarez proposed the impact
hypothesis for the demise of the
dinosaurs in 1980.
It was ridiculed and,
but he turned out to be right.
And then that became the accepted.
It takes time.
But what was the title?
People are challenging.
Those are the key turning point,
the finding of the crater.
That's what,
that's what made the difference so hard
to argue with it.
So I get,
where's your creator?
Well,
this is where perhaps we need to bring
in our phone,
a friend,
malcolm,
the comp,
one of the,
one of the younger dryas impact impact
scientists.
I mean the,
the point,
the point being made is the following,
firstly that the primary impacts were on
ice there.
That they may have been as many as four
impacts that they were on the north
american ice cap.
Some creators have been suggested,
for example,
very deep holes in the great lakes,
uh,
other creators have been and will be
looked at by the team in the,
in the coming months,
whether it includes the corozal created
that quebec,
quebec terrain.
And so on and so forth.
There are candidates that the creature
has not been found yet.
But I would be surprised if a creator
was easy to find when,
uh,
you know,
the impact is on two mile deep bass,
one of the biggest strewn fields in the
world,
which is the australian strewn tektites,
drew infield.
THere's no greater associated with that,
but everybody accepts the impact
proxies.
There's enough of them to,
to justify that.
And that's what's going on around this
impact hypothesis are related
questionnaire is not the lost
civilizations and the demise of humans,
but the mega financial extinction of
north american mammals.
So this has been long debated before the
impact hypothesis was proposed in the
competing hypotheses were over hunting.
Humans just haunted them to point where
not every last one to the point where
the population numbers get too low and
these species can survive,
or climate change or both the climate
change week in the populations than the
humans came over and over a hunted him.
Alright,
so,
and then the impact hypothesis is
proposed.
Okay.
So this was debated and it didn't fare
that well because there were a lot of
mammals and other species that didn't go
extinct that you would expect from a
massive impact like that.
It would have wiped out.
Why?
Why the selected species,
the kinds of species that humans would
hunt are the ones that went extinct.
Whereas these others didn't.
Well,
why
the largest?
There is no evidence.
The human humans hunted.
The predators.
There is evidence that they hunted
woolly mammoths,
but it's a very sparse.
I mean you have no more than a dozen
sites that show association between a
human hunting and mammoths and a lot of
those like the lubbock lake site is now
being questioned.
What was presumably we'd previously
interpreted as being butchering marks on
on the mammoth remains.
There are now being reinterpreted as
possibly natural marks on the,
on the mammoth bones,
but it's a big stretch to go from,
okay,
we've got a dozen sites where we have
mammoth remains and along with those
mammoth remains we find a few clovis
spearpoints in two or three cases we
actually flying or they have found spear
points embedded within the mammoth lake
in the rib rib cage,
but it's a very large stretch to go from
there to say that 10 or $12,
million woolly mammoths or or four
species of mamet's on four continents
were wiped out by paleo indian hunters.
Probably in bands of no more than two or
three dozen we've ever been
to a head smashed in buffalo site.
Yes,
but,
but that's a good example because
nowhere did that go anywhere close to
exterminating the species of american
bison.
But at each site has its own particular
explanation.
Could be hunting,
could it be a massive flood,
earthquake,
whatever.
They'll be a massive flood.
Yes,
exactly.
I think there you and I would be in
complete agreement.
That doesn't mean by massive global
versus local cell.
For example,
there's 50 to mammalian generra went
extinct in south America.
Why would they go extinct in south
America at about the time that humans
were moving
down there?
The younger dryas impact hypothesis
include south America,
indoor impacts there.
It does.
And,
and,
and again,
the dating of
the migration of humans into America is
controversial at this point.
Um,
you know,
there is evidence that humans were there
long before,
you know,
paul martin's idea of,
of blitzkrieg requires that the animals
be so stupid that they couldn't,
like they had no adaptive capabilities
to the appearance of a new predatory
species.
But well,
what is being demonstrated from
examining the lifeways of,
of the paleo indian peoples,
is that they had very diversified diets
and they were hunter gatherers.
Now,
why would they be choosing the largest,
most dangerous animals to hunt when they
had such a proliferation of other
smaller animals?
We know that they were foraging,
we know that they were eating seafood.
There was an and fishing,
um,
because all of this is being found in
the,
in the camps.
Um,
and then it certainly doesn't explain
the extermination of the cave bears.
The short faced bears,
the camelot,
the giant beavers,
the giant armadillos,
the american place to seen lion,
the,
the ground slots that were the size of
giraffes,
four species of,
of provosts,
indians,
meaning mammoths extinct on four
continents.
And to me like,
wait a second,
we don't,
we cannot,
we cannot invoke a modern example to,
to say,
well,
here is mallory.
Well,
that's controversial also.
Um,
and the nature of the albert's extinct
past eagle,
that's an assumption
that in people with adult adults killing
off all the saber tooth tigers.
And here's another answer to one of your
questions.
You were saying like why would some of
the animals be alive?
Well,
we know that the,
the asteroid that killed the dinosaurs
65 million years ago,
it didn't kill everything,
right?
That is a massive impact far bigger than
anything we're talking about.
And many,
many anImals survive that.
So we don't know why things survive and
why they don't.
It could be proximity to the impact.
It could be that their food source
wasn't removed.
It could be that they're predators were
wiped out and they managed to survive.
I mean,
there's a lot of animals that are still,
that are alive today in this continent.
Like for instance,
the pronghorn antelope,
pronghorn antelope,
dan flores,
who's a wildlife historian,
wrote an amazing book on it and we were
talking about the,
uh,
american savannah during,
you know,
like 15,000 plus years ago.
There was all sorts of crazy animals
millions of years ago that were like
cheetahs that were running down animals
at extreme speeds,
which is a reason why pronghorn
antelopes can run so much faster than
any of their current predators because
something much faster than them was
killing them.
And that was wIped out.
But they managed to make it.
One of the reasons why they probably
manage to make it is because they're
predators were wiped out.
It's not an even point,
michael,
if it's overkill,
it's,
it's intriguing that the ova kill
occurs,
you know,
precisely the younger dryas window
because
I think you'd agree that now the whole
story of the peopling of the americas is
pretty much up for grabs.
I mean,
clovis first was the dominant model for
a very long time and under that model
were to envisage these clovis hunters
coming in across the bering land bridge,
going down the ice free car door and
then in like 800 years with their
sophisticated fluted points,
they wipe out all the mammoths in in
north America,
but now we know that humans have been
coexisting and butchering mammas
coexisting with mammas for thousands of
years before that,
possibly tens of thousands of years
before that.
Evidence in siberia.
I don't only mean from evidence in
siberia I've.
I mean,
I can cite you from from nature magazine
just recently.
Huge,
huge number.
I don't think the yukon is in siberia,
is it?
No one's in north America.
Jack sunk mars,
you know the excavator of thE bluefish
caves in the yukon back in the 19
seventies were proposed,
was proposing that human beings had been
in America is at least 24,000 years ago.
His repuTation was utterly destroyed.
his research funding was withdrawn.
He was given no access to grants.
He wasn't able to do his work.
He was heavily penalized and punished by
the community,
and now just a few weeks ago,
we have the smithsonian coming out and
saying,
sorry,
we got it wrong.
Jack myers was right all along and tom
dillehay,
you know,
with his work in monte verde,
the shit that he had to take a.
I Think we're,
we're in a very interesting time.
The peopling of the americas is really a
paradigm that has absolutely been
overthrown.
The notion of,
well,
you disagree with ms.one and then,
which is fine.
I'm
no the mesa verde.
It's an isolated.
Again,
it's an anomaly.
It's an isolated site where all the
sites between clovis and monteverdi was
still first for thousands and thousands
of years.
Come on my condition.
Where are all the people between clovis
and motto?
My problem iS your problem.
It's your problem and bear in monte
veriday and they're there in north
America.
It's more likely that they'll figure out
why there's a dentist in south american
indians and not in north America.
It's like the nature paper.
I people cross the ocean that,
uh,
that there were.
Neanderthals are humans in san diego
130,000 years ago.
Okay.
But when you look at that.
Okay,
so they have mammoth bones.
It looks like they might have been
broken in the length and the tools,
but they're not.
Okay.
The tool kind of changing subjects here
though.
Well,
no,
no.
You're going to quibble the evidence of
human presence.
That's right.
You'll try to quibble it.
We're not quibble.
Challenge it.
You're quibbling.
Then you're going to rewrite this saying
very specifically.
That's opposing what he just said.
The reason archaeologists don't accept
earlier than clovis,
say earlier than about 13,000.
14,000 is massively,
massively accepted.
Say mesa verde for example.
Okay.
I have to bring up an image at mesa
verde.
Do accept mason is accepted like.
Well you sure about this as 24,000
years?
Fifteen plus possibly.
Possibly.
Significantly.
Yeah.
Okay,
so significantly 15 is kind of the
outside of the Window that humans came
across the bering strait.
That's possible.
Not 24.
Clovis first,
not 100 and thIrty thousand years ago.
Now,
if it turns out that that nature papers.
Right,
and that's confirmed that that does
overturn the mainstream theory for sure,
but why would you.
This is not like your field of study.
Why would you argue against the nature
of liver?
Okay,
I'll just give you ask professionals
myths.
Number five today,
decades later,
the clovis first model has collapsed.
Okay?
Based on dozens of new studies,
we now know that pre-clovis people's
slaughtered mastodons in Washington
state dined on desert parsley in Oregon
made all purpose stone tools that were
ice age version of the $13,000.
That's not no look at 24,000 years down
at the bottom.
Michael,
you know,
are you saying the smithsonian or wrong
on this?
Michael,
you're jumping to conclusions before you
even read that.
You want to be right so badly.
You didn't read the part and other
animals.
They're on a second confIrming that
humans had butchered horses and other
animals.
They're 24,000 years ago.
It says it right there and you are
arguing guested without even reading it,
which means you want to be right.
No,
no.
That's absolutely what's going on.
So I have no dog in this fight.
We started pointing at you being
published skeptic magazine and you have
no dog in the fight.
You're asking me,
why don't mainstream archaeologists
except you should be skeptical of hens
about color,
whatever you want.
it goes back 1130.
What do you think about what that says
that there's evidence they butchered
horses 24,000 years ago.
Okay.
I would have to check the site on it.
I haven't seen this article,
but now that you have seen it,
not my problem.
Okay.
Probably hear opposing this and you're
saying there's no evidence you have any
fucking article.
I'm not opposing anything.
I'm saying you certainly the reason why
scientists except these dates here
because there's lots and lots of
evidenCe for that is scientists and
eleven thousand twelve thousand is that
a scientist and you find one person that
says 24,000,
another one like two weeks ago.
It's not one person.
you're walking this without really doing
any research about it and then the
article is titled what happens when an
archeologist challenges mainstream
thinking and the smithsonian in the
month of march.
Okay.
Jack sunk mas.
It was a brutal experience.
Something that sank mas once likened to
the spanish inquisition at conferences,
audiences paid little heat to his
presentation,
giving short shrift to the evidence,
et cetera,
et cetera.
So it was always the same when he
proposed that bluefish quays was 24,000
years old.
It was not accepted.
What the smithsonian are saying is now
this is accepted.
You need to get up to speed with data.
Michael,
my,
my archeology friends like jared
diamond,
who I just checked with on this who's at
ucla,
but he certainly has a dog in the fight.
And,
and uh,
well he just says,
here's the problem.
For 50 years,
people propose pre-clovis.
ExamPles recites or they never hold up.
They always dating turned out to be
incorrect.
The carbon 14 was not calibrated right.
There was this,
there was that they never hold up.
Essentially your friend for 50 years.
Well,
you're quoting a friend who says the
evidence hasn't held up before.
Instead of quoting these articles with
these scientists were talking about the
data that's showing the human beings
butchered horses 24,000 years ago.
You're disputing it just because you
talked to a friend.
I'm saying that that has to be
confirmed.
that particular argue against it.
I'm not arguing against.
Certainly were.
No,
I'm just saying that was my right.
I feel you were arguing against it and
saying that it's not the case and then
you seem to be,
if I'm correct,
you seem to be a clovis first advocate,
but put you,
put you in reputation on the line and
say you're not going to put a label on
it.
I'm going to say in the latest evidence
that that overwhelmingly shows humans
coming across the siberian straight into
north America,
11,
12,
13,
14,
15,000 years and they definitely did.
Then they definiteLy did that.
Did they before what could push it back?
Much earlier?
It would be if they came by boat.
Okay,
so like where I live in santa barbara,
there are sites on the channel.
Islands had to go back 11,
12,000 years ago and they came by boat.
Now the problem is is if they lived on
the shores,
which is where the good fishing and
eating is,
those are underwater and short of doing
good underwater archeology,
which is hard to do and expensive and
most of it's probably gone.
We may never know.
One of my beefs with archeology actually
is that 10 million square miles of the
planet that were above water during the
ice age or underwater now and marine
archeology still mainly looking at ship
wrecks,
you know?
Well,
okay.
They do that because It's.
It's,
it's where the light is leaves the big
unanswered question.
At any rate,
so for the record It can at least say
that you completely opposed the
smithsonian's position on this that
there has been no paradigm shift will
look at this.
I haven't seen this besides anything I'm
not aware of the horse find from 24,000
years ago.
I am aWare of the hundred 30,000 year
date from the nature paper.
I have a slide on that too,
and if
tools,
they're nothing like clovis points.
It's just a big hand rock that might
have been used.
It might've been random.
Sorry,
a big hand rock is all there is before
13,000 years ago.
No,
I'm talking about 130,000 year old site.
One hundred and $30.
You're talking about the san diego is.
We don't.
We don't need to talk about that.
That raises interesting questions.
Was it neanderthals?
Was it denisovans?
Was it anatomically modern humans?
One hundred and $30,000 raises
interesting questions.
President misinterpreted site because
they aren't.
I'm not pinning anything to that.
I'm just saying yes.
That report was published in nature.
The stone tools.
It's about how the bones were shattered
and they believed the bones are
shattered.
Deliberately indicating that someone was
trying to get at the marrow indicating
more maybe or a tractor rolled over it a
couple of years ago.
No,
no,
no one had known it is excavated.
That's just speculation.
Important.
This part,
this
was one of the immediately defined,
has been quibbled by the archeological
mainstream.
Of course it's been published by the
archeological mainstream too and the
rest of the mainstream is quibbling
with.
You said that can't happen.
We will say,
what can't happen that the mainstream
won't allow a radical ideas to nature
and published it,
and the article,
the idea is being quibbled and
nature certainly would not have
published it if the evidence would not
strong.
I accept that nature is not in the
business of publishing,
you know,
fringey stuff.
It's a.
It is.
It is a radical proposal,
but it's strong enough to justify
publication in nature.
what's interesting to me is that the
immediate reaction of the archaeological
community is not say,
well,
what could this mean?
Let's,
let's look into the implications of
this.
I mean if there were neanderthals or
denisovans in north America a hundred
and 30,000 years ago,
we have a whole new scenario building
here that really should interest
everyone instead of.
Instead of the first reaction is let's
destroy this because it's really
annoying.
Let's get rid of it.
Let's prove it's wrong.
Let's suggest tHat it was a fucking
bulldozer or something like that.
Maybe it was,
I don't know.
The work hasn't been.
Hasn't been done yet,
but that instant sort of.
It's almost like an immune response to
a.
To an idea that doesn't fit into the
prevailing paradigm,
but the other work,
the work in south America,
the bluefish quays work,
that's really not controversial anymore.
It's very widely accepted.
Clovis first is a discredited and
abandoned position and I have something
else to asK you actually concerning
genetics and dna.
I'm sure you're well up on that.
I mean,
can you explain why we have a strong
Signal of denisovan dna in certain
groups of south american indians and in
australian aborigines and melanesians,
but that denisovan dna doesn't crop up
in north american indians.
How would we explain that if they all
came through the bering strait?
I have no idea.
Well,
it could be both,
but I mean this just happens to be
something I don't know anything about.
Okay.
So part of the problem and if even doing
this is that was your idea.
Well here we are talking.
This is good,
but part of the risk is that you're
going to find something I don't happen
to know about.
And then it's like,
you see,
I made my point what point that.
Okay,
so in like the history of the people of
America that,
that area,
uh,
there's always somebody that comes in
with,
it's not clovis,
it's this,
it's that.
And rarely do they last why the dates
were miscalibrated or whatever.
It's not just thAt scientists are closed
minded,
although they can be,
it's that the convergence of evidence
iSn't strong enough to overturn the
mainstream theory.
So,
but,
but it does happen.
Uh,
you know,
maybe there are multiple migrations into
north America and we just don't have all
the sites,
but when somebody comes up with a site
like that's tens of thousands of years
earlier than all the others that are
accepted here and it's over here where
all the sites in between.
Whereas it's like the gap,
the 5,000 year gap with the egyptian
complex.
Where are the sites?
If it's true,
we didn't fly it here so I had to get
there and there must be a trail,
you know,
somewhere that we could find it unless
they came by boat.
And then that's evidence is done unless
you're dealing with 24,000 years ago and
there's not much evidence to find that
navy,
but if they came by boat and that
clearly implies the head navigational
skills,
they had the ability to build boats and,
and you know,
find your way across the ocean.
You could do the coast that,
that's not quite as,
you don't need a big ocean going,
but you know,
you don't need an ocean going.
But hypothesis that you know,
that's proposed is that they came across
by,
uh,
by boat just following the shore.
You just same area as the bering strait.
Yeah,
you're just 100 feet off shore.
You go in and,
and,
uh,
most likely both.
Right?
And one of the issues of course was the
short face bear was so formidable
according to dan flores,
that it would have been a huge
impediment for people crossing on foot
anyway.
And short face bear went extinct right
around tHe time we see more evidence of
human beings entering in.
But why did it go extinct?
That's the big question.
Well,
you have to add that to the list of of
predators that there would've been no
reason for humans to have been hunting.
Yeah.
Well,
that's an enormous,
enormous animals to factors that go on
here.
There's positive evidence in favor of a
hypothesis.
Then there's negative evidence against
the mainstreams hypothesis and you
really need both,
so it's not enough to just say,
I don't accept the evidence for here
that,
okay,
that's fine.
So I just do that all the time.
What evidence?
What do you.
Let's be,
let's be speak in specifics because you
keep doing this.
You keep saying,
well,
they find things and it turns out no,
that's not true.
When you're essentially proving your
point of being a skeptic without having
any real cases.
Well and just keep saying that all of
the cases,
but no,
you're not saying you can't say all the
cases.
If you don't want to cite anything
specifically,
don't keep bringing up things that are
refuted because you don't have anything
that you're pointing to,
so you're just muddying the water.
Okay.
You're essentially pissing in the pool.
None of the clovis thing.
For example,
go back to the pyramids.
All of these,
what's been disproved?
Okay,
I'm making a different slightly
different point.
That's the problem that you're not
addressing the actual issues we're
talking about.
You muddy the water by saying things
have been tossed out the window,
so we have to be careful here and tossed
these things out the window as well that
toss out.
Just contemplate them published in
nature for example,
so let's watch what happens to the
hundred and 30,000 year old hypothesis
if it if it holds up and there's other
sites that are dated that way and so on
and so forth,
and that will be truly revolutionary and
scientists would accept it.
You see,
the problem is that when you have a very
strong paradigm like clovis first,
which really dominates american
archeology,
prehistoric archeology for very long
period,
it's difficult.
It's difficult from a career point of
view for archeologist to come up and
proposal attentive sites.
Those who did like tom dillehay let jack
sunk.
Mars paid a very heavy price for so
doing so.
The incentive to go looking for older
stuff than clovis is extremely low.
In the archaeological community as a
result of this ferocious reaction that
went on for 30 or 40 or even 50 years,
you know,
I mean can also considered the vasa kilo
excavations in,
in,
in Mexico,
uh,
where,
where the suggestion of some sort of
human presence 230,000 years ago,
I mean that good archeology,
but it was utterly dismissed and the
archeologists involved where were ruined
for getting involved in that.
It's hard to see how that's a profession
that encourages people to think outside
the box when careers get ruined and
research funding gets withdrawn for an
idea that doesn't fit the current
mainstream.
We don't like to think that,
that scientists do that.
They do that.
Are you familiar with michael kramer's
book for bitten archeology?
I know michael.
Yeah.
Okay.
So now he makes in my mind as compelling
a case as you do and for his humans were
here tens of millions of years ago.
And his book is young,
900 pages long,
tens of millions,
yet tens of millions.
Okay.
And he's a hindu.
So his ideas,
you know,
this sort of long recycling and what
evidence is it based on for tens of
millions of years not here to defend
michael kremer or to have a discussion
about michael kremer.
That's not why I'm sitting at this
table,
but my point is that michael primo is
not me.
That's right.
So,
but,
but there's lots of alternative
archeology was where I began.
There's lots of alternative archeology
books and what evidence is there to
support that?
None.
So why you bringing up that when there's
evidence that he's bringing up corrimos
evidence is similar to his.
It's mostly negative evidence that I
don't accept the data.
This,
there is this peculiar sort of footprint
looking thing.
Kramer refers specifically to the
knowledge filter.
The most useful thing about that book is
the publication of reports,
archeological surgical
reports which are no longer available to
the public,
which,
which do suggest an alternative.
But I would say it's a very useful book
to read beyond that.
I have nothing to say about.
Right.
So,
but that's not necessarily true.
You're saying his only evidence.
We mean he's pointing to like some
pretty significant evidence like this.
The sphinx thing is a geologist from
boston university propose this because
of water erosion because of water
erosion that could have only been done
by thousands of years of rainfall in his
opinion as a,
as a qualified geologists and like
that's not a lack of evidence.
I understand,
but why do no,
no other geologists archaeologists
other.
No,
that's not true.
Actually they do and I've had multiple
conversations with robert where he is
cited the fact that he has gotten a
considerable body of support from other
geologists,
not from egyptologist,
but from geologists who do recognize the
effects of severe water erosion on
limestone carbonate rocks,
and that's what we have there.
We have severe water erosion,
it appears and is preserved on the
quarry walls around the sphinx.
The sphinx itself,
as graham said,
is difficult to ascertain because of all
of the reconstruction that has gone on,
but the quarry walls,
which would have once had the very
distinct stepped profile of a typical
quarry.
I'm no longer have that.
I mean they have now they have a
textbook profile,
a parabolic profile that would be
consistent with sheet flooding,
which would be both disillusioned
because carbonate rocks dissolve in
acidic waters and what's called
courageous,
which was be the effects of water loaded
with sand sediment,
which would make it very rough,
so if you've got the sand sediment
flowing over the edge of what would have
been a quarry wall,
what you're going to end up with is a
smoothing off of the rough corners and
the final result would be a a very
rounded profile like you see there and
you would also see where the fissures in
the rock would be selectively widened
and opened by the water penetrating
those fissures.
I mean it,
it has all the earmarks of a very
textbook case of water erosion.
Don't you think?
It's very diSingenuous comparing that to
someone who thinks that human beings
have been here for tens of millions of
years with no evidence to support it
whatsoever.
He doesn't say he.
Of course he doesn't say he has no
evidence.
He has a 900 page book full of evidence.
It's the quality of the evidence.
What about the quality of that evidence?
It's okay if it was that good.
You know,
we're not geologist sitting here.
If it was that good,
why don't geologists look at it?
Go.
He's right.
They do.
They all do.
No.
Some geologists who,
some geologists who work with
egyptologists say that shock is right.
We have a geologist on the line.
Why don't we ask him,
mark will.
We can have one guy's opinion.
We could also have other guys' opinions
and get this matter has been in what
domain?
Since 1992.
It hasn't gone away.
Sharks argument that we are looking at
precipitation induced weathering on the
sphinx has not been debunked.
It has been opposed.
It has been disagreed With,
but that is different from saying it's
deBunked and shock stays solid and
strong on that issue.
He is a credentialed geologist.
He is a professor of geology at the
university of boston.
He has a right to speak out about this,
and he stated his view.
I happened to find this view very
interesting,
especially since it correlates with what
I regard as the interesting astronomy of
the site.
I think that site has origins that do go
back into the younger dryas.
That's my opinion.
I've stayed at many times and I've
presented the evidence that I think
underwrites that opinion.
You and your colleagues are absolutely
at liberty to disagree and you do.
You don't think it's disingenuous to
compare that to someone who says
something that defies our current
understanding of human beings and the
the,
the actual evolution of humans.
But you're talking about someone who's
saying that human beings,
how many millions of years old,
tens of millions.
Tens of millions.
Well,
we know for a fact,
right?
As far if you pay attention evolution.
Right,
but that's what we weren't even humans a
million years ago.
Correct.
I meAn,
there are creationists who think,
okay,
we're not talking about them.
We're talking about grandma.
I know,
but my point was that,
so here you have the mainstream
scientists.
There's graham.
He seemed so reasonable,
but there's 50 him
and each of them thinks that they're
there.
Right?
They're not
visual language.
he seems so reasonable.
Right?
So you're right there.
You're accusing me of dissimulation.
The subtext is that I'm not.
And then there's 50 patronized,
arrogant.
I don't mean deeply unpleasant and
personal approach.
I'm sorry I didn't.
I mean it to sound like that.
I really don't.
Okay.
I have a larger point that you accepted
that when you're faced with a bunch of
different alternative theories that are
coming in and it's not safe to take
physics.
I mean every physicist like you just had
lawrence krauss,
he gets these letters daily of people
saying,
I think I figured out why einstein was
wrong and he can't address them all.
And,
and,
and they're smart people.
They're thoughtful people.
They really believe it.
What do you do with that?
That's my point and I feel that's not my
problem.
And if there are alternative,
the other alternative theories,
that's not my problem either.
It's the problem for the mainstream to
sort it out and figure which to pay
attention to in which,
well,
I'm suspicious of this whole idea of the
mainstream because even looking into
mainstream,
you find so many divergent points of
view that I,
you know,
I think that's basically a fiction that
there is this mainstream that has
arrived at this consensus and that there
are no alternative ulterior motives
there and that there are no dogmas that
are being perpetuated there.
you know,
I mean,
I look at the lot of the geological
stuff in and realize that there are many
different points of view when we talk
about the,
these floods at the end of the last ice
age.
There are many divergent points of view.
There is what could be considered the
mainstream yet even that has multiple
interpretations.
And the same with this common idea.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know what constitutes the
mainstream there because there had been
a group that has opposed it at every
turn,
but at the same time,
the group that accepts the comment
hypothesis has continued to grow.
In fact,
there's even a number of,
of individuals involved that set out
specifically to to disprove it or
discredited who are now basically on
board and it has grown from being a
small handful of scientists that are now
63 scientists from 55 different
institutions that are on board with the
idea that something remarkable happened
at the end of the last ice age.
It was probably exogenic meaning
something from outside,
something from space.
There's no consensus as to exactly what
that was,
which would be normal because the,
these discoveries are in their infancy
at this point,
but there's been an attempt to discredit
the idea simply because that as the
evidence has come in over the last
decade,
it has evolved in,
in new mysteries have been opened up.
Uh,
as the evidence comes in and the claim
is being made well,
there's no consistent interpretation of
this evidence and therefore we've
debunked it.
I mean,
an example is pinta is rec.
When pinterest dalton directly am for
the younger impact
hypothesis.
I mean,
publish a paper in pen air saying
requiem,
suggesting that the impact hypothesis is
already dead.
That was in 2011.
Every single one of pinch points have
been responded to.
Those who are critical of the younger
dryas impact hypothesis rarely site.
The fact that the so called refutations
have themselves been refuted.
That new information is constantly
coming in.
I see a very one sided game being played
here with a group of academics who are
determined to demonstrate that there
could have been no possibility of
anything like a comet impact 12,800
years ago and that these 63 or 65
scientists who are proposing that I just
completely wrong and when they refute
the reputations,
I very rarely see though that that refer
to our commented upon a tall.
Again,
your,
your colleague,
the defense has dismissed the younger
dryas impact hypothesis without actually
going in detail into the debate that's
gone on.
Has this graph in his paper showing all
these different dates for the.
That's from one of the critical papers.
You know there's another side to this
argument,
so it needs to be.
It needs to be listening to what the
other side would say.
Well,
that's the point where maybe we should
have mark come on and maybe we should
have malcolm lecan come on as well
because malcolm,
the comp is actually one of those 63
younger dryas impact scientists.
What is explained to me,
people
that are just listening to this,
what is this graph that you're showing?
Well,
this is the carbon 14 date ranges from
samples taken from the younger dryas
boundary.
So this is the boundary here.
And the point of this is that there's
not a single consistent series of dates
that would consistently show.
Yep,
absolutely.
For sure.
At every site it comes in,
right there is that they bounce around a
lot here.
So now maybe mark,
this is his area.
He could come on and skype here and they
bounce around and what's,
what's the point of this for the lay
person who's listening to this?
Uh,
well.
So if you take the ones that are above
the gray line,
then those were,
those are showing that something like an
impact happened much earlier,
much later and the ones below it or that
it's much earlier.
So where's the consistency of a single
impact consistent across that middle of
that group?
I don't think there's any argument.
There was a single impact.
In fact,
there's a.
There's arguments that there was no,
there's more than one day.
We're talking about a stretch of
thousands of years and multiple impacts
dress runs when random,
200 years.
Randall,
please,
please give me your,
your [inaudible].
You're the expert of this.
Well,
these are dates for the younger dryas.
There's a big spread obviously,
but there's also a lot of possibilities
for introducing inaccuracies into the
dating.
The what's called the old wood effect
can sometimes make,
make it appear to be older than it is by
a millennium or to millenium.
But what we certainly do see here is a
clustering right around 13,000 years
ago.
That looks pretty evident to me and
everybody knows who does radio carbon
dating,
dating might have errors.
And
in it,
the one article I think that came out
last year by james kenneth and 25 others
was the by asian chronological analysis
consistent with synchronous age of
12,835 to 12,735 calibrated years before
present for younger dryas boundary on
four continents.
That's a refutation of precisely what it
is.
It's a representation of this does not
refer to that reputation.
Jamie,
could you pull up a the age of leo?
I think I gave that to you.
And go to slide number
one.
60 seven.
Wow.
One hundred and 67.
And that that refers to the go to slide
167.
Jesus,
you're not fucking around 167 slides.
Here we go.
A cosmic impact event at 12,800
calibrated years before present form the
younger dryas boundary layer containing
peak abundances in multiple high
temperature impact related proxies
including spirits,
milk,
glass and nano diamonds.
Bayesian statistical analysis of 354
dates from 23 sedimentary sequences over
four continents.
Established a model younger dryas
boundary age of 12,835 calibrated years
before present,
supporting a synchronicity of the
younger dryas boundary layer at high
probability,
95 percent.
This range overlaps that have a platinum
peak recorded in the greenland ice sheet
to end of the onset of the younger dryas
climate episode in six.
Key records suggesting a causal
connection between the impact of and
younger dryas due to its rarity and
distinctive characteristics.
The younger dryas boundary layers
proposed as a widespread correlation
data.
And randall,
if I can remember what you said
correctly,
you believe that there was probably more
than one significant impact over a
period of several thousand years.
Let me,
let me pop in on that
clean.
I don't mean to cut you off,
but the,
the,
the.
Let's be clear.
The suggestion is that 12,000,
800 years ago,
uh,
there was a comments breakup into
multiple parts.
I mean,
anybody who saw the shoemaker levy nine
nasa films back in 1994 is aware that
that comment broke up into more than 20
fragments,
all of which hit jupiter.
Sometimes creating explosions larger
than the earth itself.
All right,
so I don't think it's controversial that
comments break up into fragments and
this is the suggestion of the younger
dryas impact hypothesis that we're
dealing with a giant comet that broke up
into multiple fragments that orbits in
the tour at media stream and that four
of those fragments,
that's the the the suggestion for
largest fragments fell out of the taurid
meteor stream coming in on a trajectory
roughly northwest to southeast crossing
the north american ice cap.
And there there are up to four impact on
The,
the,
the impact is then continue across the
atlantic ocean.
There's a suggestion of impacts
in Belgium and indeed as far east as aba
herrera in Syria,
it's a,
it's a global event.
Fifty dollars million square kilometers
of the earth's surfaces is within the
younger dryas boundary field.
And so he really huge thing.
So the suggestion is that there were
multiple impacts at the beginning.
Now the next question is what happened
11,000,
600 years ago when the younger dryas
ends and global temperatures shoot up
incredibly rapidly.
And the science on that is much less
advanced than the science on the
beginning of the younger dryas.
Fred hoyle back in the 19 eighties,
was puzzled by the sudden temperature
increase at the end of the younger
dryas.
And he suggested presciently I would say
that,
uh,
this may have been caused by a comet
impact in an ocean,
so maybe other bits of the taurid meteor
stream impacted the earth.
other filaments within the stream
impacted the earth 11,000,
600 years ago,
or maybe something else caused it.
I mean,
robert schoch is in favor of
extraordinary solar activity.
Being responsible for that warming,
we don't have to know,
but that that's broadly the suggestion.
We're at the beginning and the end that
certainly impacts at the beginning,
possibly impacts or other things at the,
at the end
or club in napier and others don't.
Can in other astronomers have speculated
that there could be impact arrows epochs
in which there's a,
an enhanced possibility of the earth
being impacted.
Particularly if you have a large comet
that enters into the solar system,
begins to undergo a hierarchy of
disintegrations and basically litters
the inner solar system with the
material.
And We do know that the earth crosses
the taurid meteor stream twice each
year,
once in late june,
and um,
once in late october,
early november.
And we know that the tongue cusco event
of 19 oh,
eight,
which is not speculative,
I mean that happened.
It occurred on June 30th,
which would have been the peak of the
meteor shower.
it also came from the direction of the
sun,
its,
um,
its position in space where we're
emanate.
It's radiant point in space from which
it laminated at that time was totally
consistent with the taurid meteor stream
radiant.
So it's very possible that the,
that the tone cusco event of 19,
oh,
eight was a member of that family of
media rights.
Um,
and so,
you know,
that would be,
again,
we don't,
there's no,
nothing definitive there,
but it would be a prime candidate for
investigation that perhaps,
and again I mentioned earlier,
this goes back to the work of fred
whipple way back in the 19 forties who
began to research the target media
stream and came to believe that it was
much,
much more active in,
in the past than it is now.
That it's an old diffuse meteor stream
that at one time and like graham said,
it has a multiple objects still within
it.
KeY is the best known moment.
That's a fragment.
Original original giant comet that they
estimate might've been based upon the
amount of materials
remnant in the zodiacal light cloud that
perhaps it was somewhere around 60 miles
or 100 kilometers in diameter.
And another thing that I'm,
that I'm taken to task for is that I
report the work of cuban napier and
their suggested that the taurid meteor
stream is actually fucking dangerous and
that we should be paying attention to
it.
That it has been a hidden hand in human
history in the past.
And that it can cause us trouble in the
future.
Now this is not gloom and doom.
We have the technology to deal with the
large objects in the taurid meteor
stream.
If any filaments are on earth,
an orbit that will result in impacts on
the earth at the very least.
It's extremely unwise of us not to pay
attention to.
I'm accused of being sort of a do monger
and constantly predicting the end of the
world and this and that.
But actually I'm simply reporting
astronomers who are very concerned about
the tour with meteor stream and the
possibility that we may face further
impacts from it in the future.
That's not wool wool.
That is science,
you know?
Absolutely.
And I would agree with that and that.
And that is a form of catastrophic ism
that scientists accept as a very real
well lots.
I mean there's,
you know,
what,
if anything,
do you oppose about what they've just
said?
Nothing.
Nothing about the younger dryas period
of just a technical question you had.
Your slide was 12,800 on there.
And so get directly.
Typically the end of the oldest c 14
dates or whatnot,
and 90 11,000 or 1200 year gap
catastrophe.
No,
no.
Go back to the tend to be very clear
about
the younger dryas.
One of the puzzling things about it is
that you have cataclysm at the beginning
and this global temperature slump is
surely cataclysmic by any standards and
you have cataclysm at the end.
You have a massive spike,
a huge increase in global temperatures,
and you have meltwater pulse one b.
You have a lot of water going into the
ocean at that time.
So both ends of the younger dryas.
I cataclysmic and it's at the recent end
of the younger dryas,
11,600 years ago that we seek out
beckley tepi mysteriously
the popping up and I know you're a
staunch opponent of atlantis and that
you believe plato made atlantis up in
order to make a political point and you
may be right,
but the date that plato puts on the
submergence of atlantis is 11,600 years
ago,
9,000 years before the time of soul on
which happens to coincide with meltwater
pulse.
One b and the end of the younger dryas,
which I would have thought would cause
you to rethink your position on plato.
Just a Little.
Well,
it's interesting.
I'm open to the idea.
I tend to read myths in the same way
your guest Jordan Peterson does that,
you know,
it's a story to deliver some sort of
moral homily to is it's a commentary on
our own culture,
our society.
It's a way,
a literary way of delivering a message
to people.
That's how I tend to read.
Instead of reading them like let's see
if we can figure out what happened
historically,
but those hard data,
hard data in plato's,
whatever you think it is and
that hot data is data,
is that the submergence of atlanta's
happened 9,000 years before the time of
soul on that is a date that is 9,600 bc.
That is 11,600 years ago.
This to me is a strong reason why we
shouldn't just completely dismissed
plato's notion of a lost civilization of
the idea.
I mean the idea that say the parting of
the red sea happened because of some
impact.
That's not,
I'm not proposing that we don't go
there,
waste of time.
Okay,
but,
but there are people that think that I
don't or or that the plagues in the
bible can be a waste of time,
but deal with plato.
Alright.
So,
but my point is that some of them may
have historical origins,
some of them may be completely made up
this mythic stories for some other
reason.
You have to take them one at a time,
in my opinion,
to plato.
One is a commentary on his own culture
of athens and being too bellicose being
too warlike and then this is not good
for where we're going.
That's my opinion.
and the fact that he picks a date that
coincides with the geologically
significant date of flooding is not
really going to change your opinion.
I think.
Well,
I think again,
that's pretty amazing coincidence is it?
I mean,
we're finding that connection that
plato,
plato said that was an advanced
civilization with advanced agriculture,
advanced architecture,
advanced navigational abilities which
was submerged by the sea,
swept from the face of the earth so that
mankind had to begin again,
like children with no memory of what
went before.
And lo and behold,
he puts a Geologically significant data
on that date that we ourselves have only
known as significant in the last 20 or
30 years.
So where is this place?
This atlantis?
I mean,
so as you know,
there's online problem,
there's a,
there's a long history of people
speculating.
If we found a site that would be a big
plus,
go do more marine archeology.
Well if we,
if we take it literally,
obviously then it's below the ocean.
But you know,
I don't necessarily take plato's account
literally,
but I do say,
well,
it's rather coincidental that he,
his dating falls exactly on meltwater
pulse one b when we know there was this
huge influx of water into the ocean.
And also,
if we look at the,
his geography,
it,
it's interesting because he cites,
you know,
basically a landmass west of the pillars
of police,
which is pillars of hercules,
the straits of gibraltar,
and he places this in centrally
intermittent atlantic.
Um,
I tHink it was cramped or one of the
comp the,
the commentators on,
on him that said it was something like
three or four days say a west.
But if you look there,
there is a sunken landmass that sank at
the end of the last ice age because of
the rapidly rising sea level.
And this has been well established by
marine geology looking at evidence that,
that the [inaudible] plateau underwent
an isostatic subsidence which would have
been resulting from the rapidly rising
sea level.
We know there's no doubt that the north
american continent has rebounded iso
statically after the removal of
this tremendous mass of ice that,
that mantle north America up to anywhere
from a thousand to possibly 1500 feet.
Well,
if you,
if you do a comparable isostatic
adjustment of the mid atlantic ridge,
you'll find that the asrs island complex
are much,
much larger.
And it turns out that that might
actually be a nice place to develop a
least a maritime culture.
Something along the lines of the
phoenicians are the minoans during the
period of the ice age.
Because during the period of the ash,
the climate of the world was so much
different than now know the great basin
area was filled with huge lakes
vegetation,
forest,
savannah and grasslands,
like graham said,
with the lowered sea level,
there were a much larger areas of the
coastline your were exposed.
Um,
and that's probably where most of
people,
what resided during the ice ages near
the coast lines,
because that would have been the most
benevolent place with the rising of the
sea level.
All of that's lost.
And there's nothing really fringed about
saying,
well,
people might have lived on islands in
the mid atlantic,
especially when we know that the,
that those islands most likely had a,
a benevolent climate during the ice age.
So I,
I don't go into crystal technology and
flying machines or whatever,
all of this speculative stuff that has
created to it.
But if we just keep it simple and say,
well,
is it possible that a culture along the
lines of the minoans or the finish
[inaudible] could have existed?
Could they have existed on an island
culture and admitted atlantic?
And there's nothing really
extreme about that idea in my mind.
Even the idea that a more advanced,
sophisticated technological
technological culture coexisted with
hunter gatherers isn't too strange.
I mean sanctuary do.
So today we coexist with hunter
gatherers in the amazon jungle who don't
even know we exist.
I mean,
so I don't see.
I don't see why a priority.
That's just an impossible idea to look
my misremembering that you in your book,
you mentioned Indonesia as a site for
atlantis.
I mentioned,
I mentioned gunung padang,
not as a site for atlantis.
That's danny hilman nutter with Georgia
who is a geologist,
is indonesia's leading expert in
megathrust earthquakes.
As a matter of fact,
he has written a book proposing that
Indonesia was atlantis and the gunung
padang,
which he's been involved in
investigating a,
is a site of fromm atlantean times danny
has done.
He has proposed that.
Now,
what's interesting about Indonesia is
that Indonesia sits upon the sunda shelf
and the sunda shelf was one of the parts
of the world that was most massively
flooded at the end of the ice age mean
if you go back to the end of the.
I sAid you're not looking at the
malaysian peninsula,
you're not looking at the indonesian
islands out going out towards the
Philippines.
You're looking at a giant continent
sized landmass,
all of which went a underwater at the
end of the last ice age really rather
rapidly.
So,
uh,
I think he has a,
I think it's an interesting.
It's one of those areas in the world
where there was very large scale
flooding,
huge amounts of land were swallowed up.
Also,
the connection of Australia to new
Guinea during the ice age was also
washed away.
There's,
there's,
there's a whole range of issues
regarding sea level rise in that very
area which anybody with an interest in
these subjects should be paying
attention to.
so it's quite possible that,
like today,
many of them,
van civilizations of today are on the
water,
whether it's New York or los angeles.
And that was probably the case back
then,
and so the idea of atlanta's might not
have been about one particular area,
but many advanced areas that were wiped
out along with their knowledge.
YeAh.
So the thesis of that book,
I mentioned noah's flood,
that the two geologIsts with the black
seat,
the theory that there were rimmed with
small villages and the massive flooding
almost instantly wiped out and then that
gets passed down as the oral tradition
is these myths.
To me that's a totally reasonable,
totally reasonable.
Well,
when we get into more discussion about
the actual impact hypothesis and the
mega flooding so that we can get our
statement by gettIng them involved.
What is your geologists?
You are geologists,
you're by yourself,
and there's two of them.
What is only fair,
right?
What is your geologists opposed to what
randall and grammar proposing?
I think it's the On the impact
hypothesis versus the multiple glacial
dams that burst over periods of time
like that had that slide.
Okay.
Well let'S call him up and get him on
skype and we've never done tHis before,
so this might suck.
Well,
hopefully it'll work.
This slide here he is showing these are
each independent carbon,
14 dates of these different instant
floods in north America from each
individual ice dams.
And what separates these dates?
They're separated by,
it looks like from 20,000 to 12,000.
So all before the impact.
Well,
12,800 wasn't that
marks on the line?
What is this?
Mark would mark,
can you hear us
mark that mark defense.
Thank you very much for doing this.
We really appreciate you coming on here.
It's my pleasure.
Uh,
so you've had a chance to listen to
these guys talk.
what is your thoughts just stepping into
this cold?
Well,
first of all,
I did not mean to upset Mr. Hancock.
He seemed to be quite disturbed and I
apologize it's not disturbed him.
No,
no you haven't.
You haven't disturbed me and I'm not,
I'm not upset.
It's just simply that you're extremely
selective in what you present In your,
in your draft,
admittedly draft article that you've
chosen to put online.
Uh,
you don't represent.
You don't represent me accurately and
answer his question because I know we're
getting short on time.
Oh,
no,
no.
We're putting up plenty of time.
We have plenty of time.
Okay.
Well,
first of all tonight,
would you allow me just to address a go
beckley,
tempe for a minute?
Sure.
Would you like to address the article
first?
I think that probably would be the most
fair since we just brought that up.
Okay.
I'm sorry,
what was the question then?
Graham?
Well,
the,
I,
I read that on their various passages in
your article where you misrepresent me.
I'm sorry.
No,
I didn't rent misrepresenting.
You didn't misrepresent me.
okay.
You said that.
I did.
I said that,
uh,
that I was actually talking about
someone in Indonesia when I said you
didn't understand newton's physics.
No,
I'm sorry.
I didn't say.
I didn't say you were talking about
someone in Indonesia.
I said you were talking about.
Hey susan.
Hey,
seuss gomorrah in,
um,
in Peru is who I was talking about and
hey,
suze tamara does have very exotic views
on gravitation,
which I stayed seriously or not my
interest.
I do say he may be right,
but I don't say he's right.
I say,
this is not my interest,
and I go onto say what my interest in
his work.
You pick it back up.
You're drowning me out here.
I was asked to explain whether or not I
thought I was misleading and I don't
think I was misleading.
You can clearly state in there that may
be gravity was due to the way we've
changed orbits around the sun.
Gravity is not due to that.
It's due to mass and the inverse
of what?
What do you mean?
I don't state that.
Hey,
sue states that and I say I disagree
with it.
Oh,
come on.
I want to be respectful.
I can't really hear you when I'm
talking.
I apologize,
but I feel like you've.
You are selecting you selectively
changing the meaning of what I'm saying.
Well,
why don't you.
Why don't you quote me as these words
from my text what you say that I buy the
gravity thing of,
hey,
suze gomorrah,
why don't you quote me when I say the
opposite of what I go on to say,
not quoted in the attack is the
following quote.
However,
this isn't the part of his theory.
I'm interested in where I feel he is
solidly persuasive,
is in his observations of the anomalous
character of the monuments of the andes.
I am not putting anything on.
Hey,
suze gomorrah's gravitational ideas.
I am saying very clearly what it is in
his approach that I am interested in.
I'm not going to dismiss all of his
approach because he has an approach on
gravity that you don't like,
that's not even of interest to me,
and I say so in the book.
You don't report that.
Therefore I suggest you misrepresented
me.
Mr. Hancock.
What I brought up him for was simply
state that you didn't understand,
and I say it right there.
Did you don't understand newton's
physics,
but
I'm not even talking about.
I'm not talking about just if you don't
understand newton's physics,
not newt.
If I wished,
if I wished to make an argument about
gravity,
I wouldn't go saying that.
That isn't the part of hey suits,
gomorrah's theory that I'm interested
in.
I'm interested in the other aspect of
his work.
His observations through
feels that way.
My point was simply to point out that
you didn't understand the mechanics.
Stop wasting time here
for grant.
We the way the article is on a second.
Hold on,
let these guys talk about.
We did misrepresent him.
We did.
The way the sentence is structured,
it's clearly out of context.
We're changing.
We're going to change.
That waS taken out of context and that's
what I'm objecting.
I'm not sure why he included in the book
in the first place,
but he's not arguing about the gravity
at all.
so we will fix that.
Maybe we can get straight to the
flooding thing that,
uh,
that song talking about graham is fine
with that.
I mean,
graham,
I know there was something.
The other thing that I find to be
misrepresenting his statement yet
hancock makes the following stunning
claim quote,
our ancestors are being initiated into
the secrets of metals.
And how to make swords and knives.
What marked the fat does not tell his
readers is that I make that claim.
I don't make that claim.
I am actually reporting what is said in
the book of enoch.
That's not me who say we will the book
of enoch grand.
We'll fix it.
Okay.
Otherwise,
let's get.
Let's get back to the main narrative.
This for god's sake.
okay.
Just give me the list of them
things that will fix it becaUse that's
not the point of that.
Well,
mark,
you're obviously very critical of
graham's work and maybe erroneouSly.
So.
But let's,
let's get to what you think about what
you've heard so far.
Alright,
mr rogan.
I don't want to come across as pompous
scientists.
What I want to do is I want to protect
people from these grandiose a
assumptions graham and his first Mr.
Hancock and his first book.
Please call me grandma.
Please call me.
Grab.
Okay.
Graham and his first book in
fingerprints a suggested that that there
was a,
a continent where the civilization lived
and through some machinations,
this continent of went south and,
and ended up destroying that
civilization.
Will as a geologist that that's just,
that's just nonsense and now he comes
back and he wants us to believe that he
was all wrong and then all of a sudden
it's okay now to believe in common
strikes to kill this.
This famous civilization not supposed to
exist was duping.
People not know if he means to do it.
He seems to be doofy mock.
Oh my I work
is in print and online.
I mean I see the.
I gather that you see your role as a
protector for the public.
Obviously you feel that the public are
not intelligent enough to make
discerning decisions of their own in
this respect.
However,
to address that the public doesn't
understand the science.
Okay,
so to the degree that you're
misrepresented,
so they need the superior knowledge of
mock defense in order to understandable
finding.
They need the knowledge of sine.
Okay.
Well that's okay.
Knowledge that I have.
Let me come to your point,
which is you're saying that I proposed
one mechanism for cataclysm and
fingerprints of the gods and that I'm
proposing another mechanism for
cataclysm today.
What I proposed in fingerprints of the
gods was that there had been a gigantic
cataclysm in the ballpark of 12,500
years ago.
I looked at a number of possibilities of
which the most striking to me at the
time was earth crust,
displacement and earth crust.
Displacement is reported,
is the work of charles hapgood,
not my work,
but I do report it in fingerprints of
the gods as an excellent theory,
which explains the information.
Since I wrote fingerprints of the gods.
I've learned a lot.
I've learned a lot and I wouldn't want
to defend that theory strongly today.
I don't know if you have bought the
latest edition of my book,
the paperback edition of magicians of
the gods,
but it contains a chapter saying
whatever happened to earth crust
displacement.
I addressed the change of view in this
and I think I have a right to change my
view and I think it's.
It's healthy that,
I mean why would I stick permanently to
a view that I hold in 1995?
If new evidence persuades me that it's
wrong.
I'm sure that's a good thing.
Not a bad thing,
and I'm fundamental proposition is we
had a massive global cataclysm in the
ballpark of 12,000,
500 years ago,
so naturally it's of great interest to
me when a large group of scientists,
more than 60 of them over a period of
more than 10 years now present evidence
of a massive cognitive impact event
12,000,
800 years ago.
Exactly the way you are applying that.
There are a lot of people are to believe
in this.
There are,
there are some people that believe in
it.
I agree,
but for the most part,
I think,
uh,
taking an honest view,
the common hypothesis has gotten to vote
well,
that's complete rubbish.
Complete rubbish would also point out
that in fingerprints you had people
believing that the end of the world was
coming in 2012.
How am I supposed to take you seriously
when you say things like that and then
change your mind and we can all be done
by now.
I have absolutely changed my mind on the
mayan calendar.
Uh,
I regard the mayan calendar as an
interesting technological artifact with
a better estimate of the length of the
solar year.
Then the estimate that we have with us
today,
the mayan calendar is based primarily on
the position of the sun amongst the
constellations at the winter solstice,
and we are in an eight year window when
the sun sits astride the dark rift of
the milky way between the constellations
of sagittarius and scorpio on the winter
solstice.
That window is 80 years wide.
So the story of the mind calendar by the
way,
isn't actually quite over yet,
but I'm not.
I'm means
yes,
I know exactly what precession means.
Okay.
Well,
all of this stuff that you claim is on a
procession of procession is the,
is the,
the earth spinning like a top,
don't teach with running through comic
clouds.
and yet you're saying that somehow we're
on some sort of cycle where the comments
are going to come back and strike the
earth.
Uh,
right now,
sometime during the next 40 years.
That's what you said in magicians.
Now that's what,
that's what?
That's what [inaudible] club and bill
napier and emilio sporadic carto say I'm
new.
You're the one who said it in your book.
You just got all over.
Mr. Michael shermer for,
for saying the same things about other
people.
I want to know what you think,
but mark told me what you think.
I am a reporter and I make it very clear
that
you're talking to them about signs mark.
We got to.
We can't talk over each other.
I'm a reporter and it is my job to
report the work of other people and I
report the work of viktor club,
bill napier and emilio,
aesthetic carto,
all of whom draw attention to the taurid
meteor stream and who regarded as the
greatest collision hazard facing the
earth at this time and who specifically
indicate that we may run into a filament
of the taurid meteor stream in the next
30 years.
That is going to be very bad for our
civilization.
It's not my thing to do with precision.
When,
when did I say it had anything to do
with procession?
You have a whole session in magicians.
Indeed as a clock,
as a timer,
as a way of going back through the ages,
but I'm not saying precession is causing
this encounter with the taurid meteor
stream and go find the paragraph where I
say,
no,
no.
What you're saying is that we're on a
cycle.
The 12,000 years ago this civilization
was destroyed and now you're saying,
oh,
that civilization was so smart that they
knew we were going to go through another
shower and we're all doomed in the next
40 years.
You didn't say doomed and in magicians
like you did in fingerprints,
but we must conclude that that's your
opinion because I don't know anybody
else that you referenced on that issue.
Well,
it has nothing to do with that.
It's not even on that cycle.
I never saw a cycle of about 21,000
years.
Twenty five cycles per session.
Twenty 5,920 years.
Actually,
it's not awful.
Precession one degree every 72 years.
Give or take a small margin.
That is the precession,
the teaching grandma to suck eggs here.
So anyway,
I guess this has just been going on all
day.
You can't criticize michael for bringing
up other people and we're saying strange
things and compare and say,
oh no,
you can't say that because it's not
about me.
It's not true.
You're.
You're doing the same thing.
You're reporting about other people and
saying,
nonsense.
I'm reporting the work of viktor clue.
Bill napier and emilia,
sped carto.
I also indicate that I strongly support
that work.
That's as far as I go.
Mark is if I could
stop you here.
So you think that this comment wiping
out all the ice age megafauna theory has
been debunked?
Is that what you're saying?
No sir.
I have not seen that.
Well,
I think that if you read the literature
carefully,
the majority of scientists right now,
and I know that this is still going,
you know what I like about the common
people,
is that they're doing it in the
scientifically right way.
They're getting people to review the
material.
They're getting people to go through
that gauntlet to where they get
criticized and they make sure that they
do things right and to get it out there.
Firestone did this in 2007.
He was crucified.
He's come back,
his,
his group has come back with a lot of
good stuff,
so I want to wait and see this play out.
I said I didn't like paper that we're
going to have to wait to get a
conclusion here.
So I'm not saying that they're wrong,
but right now if I read the literature
as a scientist,
I have to say that the comment guys are,
are,
are getting hit pretty hard.
What do you take?
What do you make of the latest platinum
paper in nature?
Scientific reports,
the platinum anomaly across north
America and it's coincidence in time
with the greenland ice cores and the
platinum anomaly there.
What do you say to that?
Well,
I say that and maybe we can bring him
on.
The problem with that is,
is that what does platinum have to do
with the common,
you know,
platinums are high and asteroids,
but they're not high in comments.
Comments are icy bodies.
I saw the paper,
I read it.
Um,
I think it's interesting,
but I can't for the life of me figure
out how he's correlating it and he has
in,
in the different areas of the clovis,
he has platinum concentrations that are,
that,
that are seemingly not matching up there
outside the younger dryas,
other inside the younger dryas.
I'd like to,
I'd like you to show them
to understand what he's trying to say.
It doesn't refute the common hypothesis.
Let's bring malcolm on since he's one of
the coauthors of the platinum paper.
This is going to get super complicated,
but let's try it one color at a time.
We could only do one color at a time
apparently,
but I think my malcolm,
you know,
should,
should have it.
I don't want to criticize him if he
can't be here.
That's okay.
You can talk a little bit if I may,
about a go go beckley,
tempe,
because I've read a schmidt.
I know that schmidt never ever found
anything to suggest that there were
anything in the early part of beckley,
tippy that,
that we're not hunter gatherers.
They all were hunter gatherers.
You know,
he found 20.
I think I,
I may be wrong on this,
but I think he found 22,000 stone tools
there.
Uh,
when he dug that place up,
any domesticated animals,
he never found any domesticated grain.
The,
he found tons of bones of animals.
So we know that about 100 to 200 people
were probably working on go back to the
top at one time and they were fed by
wild animals and grain.
So there's no reason to go out on a limb
here and say that some magical
civilization
came in.
And by the way,
that's another thing that drives me
crazy.
You're saying that these guys were
magicians.
You're saying that they had secret
knowledge.
What possible secret knowledge that they
give to the people that go back to tibi.
How can you possibly not saying that the
word magicians of the gods comes from
the app kalu in ancient sumeria and they
were considered to have superior powers
that they were considered to be
magicians have a salt.
Am I?
Should I not report that?
Because it's there in the sumerian text,
you should tell us what michael's been
asking all day is what were their super
powers.
I'm not saying that they had super
powers this the sumerians who said that
I simply report that you can regard that
as a cop out if you like,
but I am a fucking reporter book
magicians of the gods because that's the
direct implication of the blue.
They were the magicians of the calls.
Like you're saying they had magical
powers to me.
No,
I'm saying that they were the magicians
of the gods as they were called in an
ancient culture.
That's all.
I just want your audience to know.
That schmidt who worked there for 20
years that had didn't go there for two
days and look around and take some notes
and leaving on a book on it.
He worked there for 20 years and he
found date with dates and everything.
He found that there were hunter
gatherers.
They're building those mega list just
like you went to.
If you went to easter island,
can be found the ali and,
and you said,
oh my gosh,
there must have been some secret
civilization that made these milan
because stupid hunter gatherers couldn't
possibly make these will.
We know that there were no special
people on easter island.
It had to be made by a hunter gathers.
Why would you poopoo uh,
sorry.
Are you saying I have to call it.
Are you serious?
Are you seriously saying that the
inhabitants of easter island were hunter
gatherers?
Oh,
absolutely.
And if fatter effect,
we saw that little island in the pacific
ocean,
the pacific ocean until about 1000 years
ago on hold on to until about 1000 years
ago.
What do you think they hold a big
civilization mark?
Please let them respond.
Go ahead.
Well,
first of all,
have you met claire?
Did you meet klaus schmidt?
Do you know him personally?
You know that I haven't met him.
Okay,
well,
I did meet him.
I do know him personally.
I did record.
I did record my interviews with him with
his agreement and and what he states
clearly I don't disagree with you that
the people around go back to tempe,
were hunter gatherers when go back to
tempe was started.
What precisely intrigued klaus smith was
the possibility,
his praise,
not mine,
that got back.
Lee tappy was a center of innovation,
a place where new ideas were
deliberately seeded in spread out in the
population.
I have klaus schmidt on record saying
that I quote him saying that in my book
and that to me is a very interesting
proposition because it suggests that we
have a site here that is being used to
mobilize the population and to transfer
to theM,
but knowledge of agriculture which
suddenly appears around go back at the
time that go back to the tappc is
functioning.
What do you mean by that?
What I mean by what I mean by suddenly
it's klaus schmidt bet stated very
clearly that these are the people that
very same people who made go back to
tempe and claw schmidt's view are the
people who quote unquote invented
agriculture.
If you don't mind me interrupting here
for a second,
what about easter island?
Was easter island established by a
hunter gatherers or not?
You were saying no.
You say it was established by a hunter
gatherer.
As I say,
not.
I say easter harlem was an agricultural
society.
What's that?
Hunt and gather on a tiny island.
Have you been to easter island?
I have six times and you know,
you can walk across it in three hours.
What's that?
A hunt and gather on that.
Oh no,
you're misunderstanding my point.
These are not sophisticated people.
Okay.
But sorry,
you sat and go quickly tapping.
I think that you got it right.
In fact it's a unesco site.
We all recognize how important it is,
but what,
what,
what I think michael and I can
understand is how this ties into some,
some magnificent civilization.
There's nothing there that indicates
that they were influenced by some other
civilization except that they started
out as hunter gatherers and then they
evolved into a,
um,
an agricultural society.
And that's what makes it a great site.
Can I answer you?
You are seriously saying that there's
nothing there.
I mean,
the largest megalithic site on earth,
7,000 years older than stonehenge is
there.
There's no background to it.
No evidence of practice or the
megalithic site itself is the problem
for me.
Okay.
I honestly,
we've got mega list in quite a few sites
and by the way,
you're right,
there's a mega list just down the road
from go beckley,
tippy,
and they're probably so that several
other.
I can see them on maps and we need to
get to the wonderful amount of work to
do there.
You bet.
So I think grammar is good.
Agreement
is,
is that I don't think that there's any,
any need to call upon this great
civilization that you,
you say exist.
well,
to me the simplest explanation is a
transfer of knowledge transfer of
technology.
I've been writing about the possibility
of a lost civilization for more than
quarter of a century.
That's what I do.
I hope that it's a useful contribution
to the debate.
I mean,
archeologists can choose not to listen
to anything I say to dismiss me as a
complete lunatic as they often do.
To accuse me as you do in writing of
duping,
the public of conning,
the public and so on and so forth.
When you did use the word conning,
actually it's in the very last paragraph
of your article because I got it right
here in front of me.
We will fix it.
This was the first thing I wrote.
I just put it up for my students.
Well,
it's there.
Well wait,
hold on.
I am.
I am left with what I'm left with.
Is that hancock?
Am I going to put my reading glasses on
so I can read this properly?
What I am left with is quoting you,
mark,
is that hancock has a real knack for
wanting a hellacious number of people
into buying his books mean that's a
direct
ad hominem insults.
it's online.
In your article,
do you stand by it or not,
but listen,
I apologize to you for the use of that
language.
Just don't want you to.
Because I do,
but
you used it in the first place.
I think you're misleading your students.
Why would you say that?
You're just putting that online for your
students as if that's not a big deal.
You're putting it on the internet.
It'S a salient just putting it online
for your students and you've been proven
incorrect.
And how many different times in this
article now?
Well,
about seven,
correct.
I haven't been proven incorrect.
Well,
you have,
you misquote,
you don't give the context.
The neva guy.
Even michael and even michael has said
that the skeptic article will not,
will not reflect these outer context
statements that you're making here.
Right?
So the core is,
is the impact hypothesis likely to be
true or not?
And as an independent phenomenon,
is it connected to go directly to epi in
the younger dryas?
I mean,
that's kind of what we're getting at.
So then we can,
maybe you can explain that graph that
shows all of the glacial dam bursts and
the dating of those as,
as thousands of years before the 12,800
year impact.
Yeah.
We need To know that you guys get into
what does that,
what does that mean?
Well,
which map is at which map on your,
um,
which map mark?
Uh,
I'm sorry,
it's the glacial map of western
Washington or Washington state.
Yeah.
Jamie,
I'll put it up.
This is,
by the way up.
I should to protect michael here.
I,
I submitted this.
Michael made immense amount of changes
on that paper.
I put it up because I wanted my students
to see it.
I had no idea that people would go
online and look at that like you and
unfortunately you've sent tens of
thousands of people.
Probably two of my letting them know
it's on here and I'm sorry for that.
Is it okay to just put that up online
for your students?
How come you don't have any problem with
that?
But you do have a problem with it as it
stands being released to the general
public?
Um,
well,
you know,
maybe it was like a nice stand by
everything I said except for the
personal comment at the end.
Well,
we'll see.
Yeah,
let's,
let's put up this mess.
Good at.
Back to the map.
Okay.
The brown areas are now I have to
emphasize that,
that the scab lands is very famous.
People have been working on geologists
have been working on this for more than
a hundred years I bet,
and very intricate detailed mapping and
we now know what areas have been flooded
that's in the brown.
The green areas are the old glacial
lakes.
Uh,
one of them you can see is the columbia
lake and the other one on the far right
over in Montana.
That's lake missoula.
Now I guess my point here is,
is that you guys want to make the
flooding out here to be immense and I
think brits original idea was that there
was this one flooding,
but then brex came to,
to understand after looking at the data
and all of the geology geologic work,
that it wasn't just one flood,
that it's many floods.
And that was the point of all of those
dates that I show you that there were,
there had been at least 17 specific
floods dated.
There are probably as many as 40 to 50
floods out there and they're all
probably related to a glacier dams
breaking.
Now.
Where in the world would you ever say
that this small area relative to an
entire content,
why would you say that this is evidence
for a common strike?
Common strike,
not even the comment guys are saying
that this flooding out here is related
to a con because there are a large
number of area,
a very small number of,
of area,
actual area that is flooded.
If you take a look now at my dates or
not my dates but the dates.
Um,
do you have that michael?
The one with.
We're going to bring that up.
But uh,
let's let randall carlson address you
because he's,
I mean he's,
he's got a point that if you just look
at if you can find your,
your examination to this area,
but the point is you've got evidence of
mega flooding all around the eye sheet
margin from the atlantic to the pacific.
You've got the work of key kikuyu and
lord in the midwestern states,
South Dakota,
North Dakota,
eastern Montana.
You've got massive spillways out there
that discharged off the ice sheet.
You have glacial river warren.
That was undoubtedly a formed by most
likely glacial lake agassi,
and you've got the st croix river where
I took graham a couple of years ago that
had mega floods down.
If there were mega floods down the
Mississippi river,
there was glacial lake Wisconsin that
discharge down to Wisconsin river,
left the wiSconsin dells.
There are the finger lakes in New York
that probably were created by a massive
floods emanating off of that scholar
scoured exactly right.
They were scoured and they were probably
scoured by subglacial floods that were
coming under a high pressure because you
know,
you have the drumlin fields that are
just to the south of them and I,
you've probably seen the work of john
sean,
a fair beanie and bruce rainy and knows
Canada drones is crazy.
Well,
why?
Why would that be?
Why would,
how do you propose the gremliNs then
were formed?
Oh,
easily.
Uh,
these glaciers came forward and tops top
the,
the terminal moraine and spread to the
moraines out to,
into drones.
But how,
I mean,
you've got,
you've got features that look like
they're totally fluvial he produced.
You have,
they look like inverted motels.
You look at the internal stratification.
How does glaciers create internal
stratification?
I've looked at,
I've looked at at numerous drum,
I'm in Canada,
I've looked at drum in New York state.
I've looked at gremlins and probably a
dozen different places and where you can
see exposures you see stratification.
You don't see if,
if glaciers are grinding over a
deformable sub straight,
how is it that they produce anything
other than a chaotic jumble of glacial
till you can actually see layer and I've
seen it myself and we can pull up
pictures of it here in a minute and I'd
like for you
explain to me you do that because I'm
not disagreeing with you a drama and by
definition is made up of till I think
we're getting kind of technical for this
audience,
but you know an esker is something
that's stratified,
not adrenaline.
You're missing.
You're missing identifying them as
drumline.
No,
I am not misidentifying gremlins.
I know very clearly the difference
between an asker and a drama and I've
looked at many askers.
I've hiked on him.
I put sloan over him in the finger lakes
or gouged.
They are gouged.
Yes.
Are they gagged by glaciers or are they
also gouged by subglacial mega floods?
That's the question in that.
I think that's a fair question to ask
and if we look at some of the studies,
we find out that the,
that the depositional material in them
is massive.
It's not stratified.
It's massive,
is if it Was dumped in there over a very
short period of time.
Let me go back to the,
uh,
to,
to the bigger picture,
but hold on a second,
but what's your point about that?
The,
I'm sorry.
Respond to that.
What he just said.
What am I responding to?
Oh,
look,
we're going to have to disagree.
I mean,
what am I supposed to argue?
I don't want to get into an argument
with him here.
Keith thinks that they're done by water.
I entered the traditionally the way most
geologists seed the grit the finger
lakes is there out there are parallel to
one another if,
if he thinks it's water.
Okay,
what can we do?
We can disagree.
I guess.
Let me go back up to the,
to the main glacier of the glacier,
while he broke her,
suggested in nine in the nineties,
uh,
that water,
potentially,
uh,
was changed from flowing down the
Mississippi valley into the atlantic or
the arctic.
No one has been able to find any
evidence of flooding towards the
atlantic or regarding.
So when you say there are all kinds of
evidence of flooding up there,
wally broecker backed off of his,
of his theory because we couldn't find
any flooding.
Why he backed off of was the idea that
the draining of glacial lake agassi
triggered the younger dryas because
they,
the,
the dating of the draining of glacial
lake agassi was post younger dryas,
and so that's what he backed off of him
necessarily because look,
we know that there were,
that,
there were somewhere and then carefully
dayton carefully math.
You can watch the old tide glacier move
back lorraine after lorraine,
and there are no holes in that moraine
that,
that suggests flooding.
There's no change in the lake levels of
lake agassi.
There's no evidence there.
Oh,
randall,
for flooding.
you've got it wrong.
If you look at the mapping that the
careful mapping that the geologists have
done,
you've just said that there was no
change in the level of lake agassi.
How is that possible?
I mean,
as the ice receded,
the glacial lake agathy expanded and at
some point that finally breached right
there at my big stone lake in Minnesota
and basically carved out the Minnesota
river valley,
which geological studies have confirmed.
They call it a river warren,
and he confirmed it.
Essentially it was carrying it's pake.
Peak discharge was roughly 4,000 times
greater than the modern Minnesota river
that flows there
to the Mississippi.
The Mississippi then conveyed that water
into the gulf of Mexico and deposited
huge amounts of delta material that new
orleans is built on.
Now
you know you're trying to make a flood
or a flood isn't.
There's a difference between a glacier
melting which causes a lot of water and
a comment striking which cases creates
copious amounts of water.
I think you guys referred to it.
The last time is a tsunami.
There is no evidence of a tsunami in
north America.
Have you been?
Finally,
here's another question.
Why do you guys,
why aren't you guys talking about north
America when you're atlanta?
This is supposed to be in Egypt or are
you guys have run around?
You found some evidence of flooding in
north America and somehow this relates
to a destruction of atlantis in some
lost civilization.
That's what I'm talking about now.
I'm not talking about that.
We know there was a fan of scan dni
sheet.
We know there was a core dni sheet.
We know there was a laurentide ice
sheet.
We know they all melted.
We know that there was somewhere around
6 million cubic miles oF ice wrapped up
in those,
in those ice sheets at the end of the
late glacial maximum.
They're all gone now.
they had to melt.
That was an enormous amount of water and
I don't know if you have been out to the
scab lands.
I've been going back to the scab lands
and the area of glacial lake missoula
since 1970.
I've been across That thing 60,000 miles
back and forth.
I have over 10,000 photographs of the
material in the field and I can tell you
those floods were enormous.
They were
beyond your cherry picking.
Look at the map.
You shown some pictures.
You know we can measure those current
ripple marks that you'd show.
We can measure how much water went over.
All you have to do is measure the
current ripples.
You can go into cameras
prairie and you've got a current ripple
field there that is about seven miles
long.
I know it very well.
Okay.
And the high watermark and narrows at
4,000,
200 feet above sea level.
The floor of cameras,
prairie is just 1400 feet lower than
that.
So we know that there were 1400 feet of
water that pass through canvas prairie
and down into the
flathead river.
No,
we don't.
Because regarding.
Are you disregarding the high water
mark?
The bottom of the bottom of the canyon
to the top of the canyon is not what it
was when the water first started flowing
in that area.
You caN't take the bottom of the canyon
and say,
oh,
there must have been 4,000 feet of water
here.
I'm not talking about a canyon.
I'm talking about cameras.
Prairie basin,
which is not a canyon.
It's a base of road at one time.
Well most of the material in near was
washed in,
so I mean we don't know how much it
would have eroded until somebody does
some core samples to get down to
something that can be dated to earlier
delayed glacial maximum.
But the floor of camus prairie is,
is thick layers of very coarse gravel
boulders and this is what composes the,
the current ripples that you see there.
I mean,
I,
I don't see how you can look at those
current ripples that are sometimes 40
and 50 feet in amplitude with two and
300 feet cord length and say that that
wasn't a catastrophic flow.
Maybe it wasn't.
It was a catastrophic flood,
but it wasn't like a tsunami.
Then how would you characterize your,
and we can,
you know,
we can do,
we can play this game.
Are you saying there are every
geologists on the planet practically
says that there were about 40 different
floods until you came along
familiar with the workday and victor
baker or ruSsell bunker or a number of
others that have challenged the 40
floods hypothesis and.
And are you going to tell me that those
current ripples in cameras prairie are
created?
They're,
they're the product of 40 separate
floods.
Oh,
absolutely.
In fact,
when you show me your pictures,
I could see the flow changes in that.
Oh,
don't give me the year and credulous
stuff doesn't mean you're right.
You do the credit us all the time.
Mark.
Well,
so let's say some pretty incredible
flood
is created.
The cameras prairie.
I want,
that's what you're saying.
That's,
that's the product of 40 separate
floods.
Correct.
So many floods in,
been in there.
I know that there are going their county
and,
and I last read something to the effect
of 40 somewhere.
Yeah.
That's based on the work of richard
weight goes back to the,
to the early eighties and I think he's
got.
No,
no,
go,
go to,
go to his graph and we go to his graph.
Who graph?
Which graph is this mark?
It's the one right below the map.
Yeah,
this one.
It's the dating floods.
Here we go.
We're,
we're at that right now.
I think I,
hopefully,
hopefully we're disagreeing in,
uh,
as comrades here.
I'm just trying to give you some data
here.
Look at those.
Uh,
those missoula floods,
a lake,
lake missoula.
He's gone dated.
You're seeing the dates.
He's got standard deviations.
One and two standard deviations on,
on,
on the median there.
Uh,
so we've got these,
these things pinned by multiple carbon
dates.
The little bell curves there.
Show how many carbon dates he's got and
you can see that these are documented
very,
very well.
So I don't understand why you're,
you're,
you're so opposed to multiple floods.
In fact,
I've heard in the last time you guys
were on this show,
I heard you say that you thought there
were multiple floods.
Now you're trying to argue against that
idea.
I,
I still,
I still think there were multiple
floods.
I think we have to look at two distinct
regimes of floods though,
and,
and as far as the radio carbon dating,
the thing we have to be really careful
of is that floods will entrain older
sediment and in that older sediment
there could be radiocarbon dated
material that doesn't really date that
that time of the flood,
but was excavated by the flood in,
trained into flood waters and then
redeposited.
So
that's a major problem with radiocarbon
dating anytime you're looking at flood
sediments.
And I do believe there were multiple
floods.
That's,
you know,
I think it's a misinterpretation.
I think that I only think that there was
one flood,
but there,
the problem is here and I do,
I think we're colleagues and my approach
to this as just like,
you know,
in the ama ama,
when two guys get out there and try to
beat the crap out of each other,
and then at the end of it they gave each
other a hug.
That's kind of where I'm coming from.
So,
you know,
there's nothing
personal,
each other a hug,
but I feel the same way.
and by the way,
you guyS are very bright and,
and
very knowledgeable.
Well,
you know,
I,
I really value this because I'm looking
for.
I'm looking for holes in this idea very
much so and,
and I have done some serious thinking
about this over many years and I have
interviewed most of the geologists that
have worked on it.
I've been in half a dozen field trips
guided by the,
the,
the main geologists that have worked on
this and had a chance to dialogue with
them and,
and you know,
I'm convinced that,
you know,
there's still some,
there's a lot to be learned about this
and,
and I think we need to be looking at,
like you said,
the big picture and we could get back to
a discussion of the finger lakes and how
they formed.
I think that's important.
I think we could get back to a
discussion about drum lens and how they
formed.
You know there is studies on the valley
heads,
maureen at are at the south end of the
finger lakes that have,
I can't think of who did it right now.
I could pull it up but basically said
there it's water deposited,
but,
but there's a lot of unresolved issues
about what happened during this
transition,
planetary transition out of the last ice
age and I think it's important that we
have these discussions that we have
these dialogues and we try to get to the
bottom of what actually happened without
imposing too many preconceptions upon
our models because I think we're looking
at something very unprecedented here.
Randall,
I couldn't have said that better.
It was very well articulated.
Let me go back to the big picture.
If I could just for a minute,
because I want to address something that
graham said earlier and that is the gram
seems to have this idea that,
that comments break up all the time,
but,
but people didn't understand.
Um,
I,
I think comets and meteorites understand
that the,
the,
the comment schumer levy or whatever it
was that broke up,
it broke up because of the gravitation
of jupiter.
We would not expect these comments to
break up andrea and into the atmosphere
is one of the problems that the common
people have had.
A firestone once suggested a four
kilometer wide comets striking the.
Now they've broken it up into multiple
comments.
The problem is you can't get it
separated if a comment breaks up,
it's very hard to separate it so that it
hits in multiple places.
And so,
so this is a big picture kind of problem
that the common people are having with
the scientists.
So you may be able to get it to hit,
uh,
the north american ice sheet.
But I'm telling you that the studies are
showing that you're not going to be able
to do this without leaving some marks.
And so far nobody's been able to find a
credit.
Do you know that,
that they're suggesting that a four
kilometer comment,
if it couldn't break up,
it would generate 1 million a crater.
Meteor craters.
You know how big that was?
That was 49,000 years ago.
We,
we don't see that in the,
in the climate record.
Forty 9,000 years ago,
we should see we don't see it.
It's a barely a little thing that they
have a huge comet strike.
Malcolm malcolm has been standing by for
best part of three hours.
I
since he's a member of the common
research group.
Wouldn't it be a good time to bring it
up?
Yeah,
we can bring them on as long as mark has
satisfied that he said his piece,
but unfortunately mark,
we can have two people on the phone at
the same time.
Okay.
Do you.
I really appreciate you having me on.
I appreciate you coming on to and I'm
glad you guys especially you in randal
seem to have ironed out a lot of your
ideas.
I think there was a great guy.
There's a lot to be learned here
obviously,
and there's a lot that already has been
learned and this is an unbelievably
fascinating subject and I think
oftentimes when these debates get
heated,
a lot gets lost and who's wrong or who's
right,
but I think what we can all agree on is
that what we're dealing with is an
unbelievable point in and the history
of this planet and trying to figure out
what caused it and why is some really
fascinating stuff.
So mark,
I really appreciate your time and really
appreciate you,
uh,
you imparting your knowledge on us,
if at all possible.
I would love to kind of keep some of
this dialogue going because I really
would value your input and trying to
write you randall,
um,
and I couldn't get through.
I'm not sure why I'm not either because
if I were to see that,
I definitely would've responded.
So please send me.
I'd love to.
I will definitely connect you guys after
this is over and thank you once again,
mark.
Really,
really appreciate you calling them.
If I can just say I do hope you'll
revisit your article and just have a
look at the context in which you
presented me.
They're absolutely.
thank you,
mark.
okay,
now
we're going to call her number two.
This is a fascinating podcast stuff.
And your friend who is waiting is
malcolm mccomb.
Mark,
one of the common research group
scientists.
This is a large and diverse body of
scientists who come at it,
the material with different expertise in
different areas of knowledge.
Uh,
it happenS that malcolm is a co author
of the recent diary regarded highly
significant paper finding a platinum
anomaly across north America and I would
hope you might begin with addressing why
that might indicate a comet impact.
Right.
Is malcolm on you?
Shouldn't be malcolm.
Can you hear us?
I can hear your.
Excellent.
How are you,
malcolm?
Thank you very much for joining us.
Have been here.
Uh,
so give us your thoughts on what graeme
just said,
if you would,
as to why,
uh,
why it makes sense that it was a comment
that hit and why there would be these
large deposits of these.
What was it exactly in that time in the
recent paper,
but,
but malcolm is also an expert in
magnetic microsphere yules and I think
he can address that issue as well.
The whole range of proxies of impact
proxies and malcolm,
please just give us your thoughts on
this entire phenomenon,
if you will.
I will.
Happy to be here.
Happy to have you.
Is he breaking up?
No,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
Malcolm.
I think there's an issue.
Seems to be.
Can you go.
I know what's going on.
I've got a feedback.
I forgot to turn off this.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
You got to meet that other video.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
You were listening to us at the same
time as talking to us here.
You're going to get.
You're,
you're getting us on like a 42nd delay
or something?
Yeah.
Okay.
We call them out.
Actually,
I was very interested to hear mark's,
uh,
his initial statement kind of put me
off,
but his,
uh,
his subsequent statements I thought
were,
were pretty accurate and there is,
there are
many problems with the,
uh,
the hypothesis that there was an impact
and that's the way I consider it.
I don't really think in terms of a
common impact,
I think in terms of an extraterrestrial
impact because I don't think we've
proven a cognitive pack.
I don't think we've proven.
We don't think we know what kind of an
impacted was.
There's too many questions that have to
be answered.
Uh,
so I can't sign up to say that I'm
defending the comet impact hypothesis
because I don't frankly know what it
was.
A,
we have a lot of evidence that appears
to be extra terrestrial in nature.
We have magnetic,
micro sterols.
Um,
I can give you the most frequent
criticism we get is that the,
the evidence has not been replicated.
And that's where I thought mark was
going when he,
his initial statement was that the
comment impact hypothesis has been
debunked.
And I think what he meant was if I can
speak for him,
um,
was that the fact that it was a comment
has been debunked.
I don't think that's necessarily true
yet.
It just isn't indicated that,
uh,
that it was a comment.
It's we have indications that it was
more of an asteroid hit than anything
else.
And I can conceive of a rubble pile that
somehow became a,
this associated all of there be,
there have to be a mechanism or a model
for that.
And I don't think we have a model for
that.
Um,
asteroids come in many flavors and a
rubble piles or certainly one loose
loose aggregate,
some material that could become
separated possibly.
But,
uh,
I just don't know.
I just don't know at this stage.
Um,
I
guess the biggest criticism that we
faced in terms of the impact hypothesis
is that the evidence has not been
replicable and we now have,
I guess for three or four,
uh,
evidence lines that had been replicated
By numerous independent groups.
Google's the nano diamonds,
whiCh may be the most controversial of a
bunch of the evidence lines that's been,
that's been replicated by four different
groups,
independent,
uh,
five different studies.
The magnetIc microspheres which were
initially
treated very hostile late because they
didn't understand what we were talking
about.
And some of that was a self inflicted
wound on a part of the initial study,
uh,
which didn't show.
We were really refining and uh,
that's been corrected.
And there's the same objection or
criticism is being made.
Magnetic microsphere roles are typically
very well.
They're melted and then their quenched,
uh,
they,
they said that they're subjected to high
temperatures and then those temperatures
are,
are rapidly reduced,
which is sort of accepted to be
characteristics of an impact.
So we've got that evidence of an impact
and that's been replicated by 10
different independent groups and
including many of the same sites
that were originally disputed.
So then the,
the disputation has been largely based
upon the failure to do the most basic
part of the protocol,
which is to,
uh,
to do the scanning electron microscopic
analysis of the spheros.
Okay.
that,
that is the microsphere,
the,
and the nano diamonds.
The other is the discovery of platinum
iridium osmium,
which are the platinum group elements
which are characteristic of an asteroid
impact.
And we found some evidence of,
of,
uh,
of iridium,
not,
not a lot,
but there had been certain sites that
are rich and iridium at the.
And once again,
this is at the younger dryas boundary,
not above,
not below.
It's there at that boundary so that they
seem to be pretty solid.
And iridium is indicative of an impact
of extraterrestrial origin,
correct?
That's correct.
The platinum is simply just another
more,
more plentiful,
a platinum group elements,
obviously that's why they're called the
platinum groups.
Uh,
osmium is one that is usually associated
with iridium.
There are now 11 studies by independent
groups that have confirmed the,
uh,
the occurrence of platinum osmium we're
already in,
so it looks to me like the evidence is
piling up on the most recent one,
of course is to platinum study by more.
That just came out a few months ago now.
Random girls.
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but randall carlson just had us pull up
some images that we're looking at.
RAndall,
please explain what this is.
Well,
this is from malcolm's 2012 independent
evaluation of conflicting microsphere
real results from different
investigations.
This is his supplementary information
figure for.
So it's just so that the people watching
this can,
can actually see what you're talking
about when you're discussing the rapid
quenching effect on the surface of the
microsphere oils.
So we've got up on the screen here,
supplementary information,
figure four where you've got the
microspheres from topher,
blackwater draw and papaw cove.
So just,
just so people can see what that surface
texture looks like.
Like
a.
Yeah,
you see these,
they looked like leaf,
like structures across.
Some of them are harder to see,
but they're there.
If you see the original image,
it's large enough and clear enough to
actually see these,
what we call dendritic structures or,
or a almost like a carpet.
We've,
those are essentially truncated
crystallization.
It's a,
it's a crystallization process that's
clenched.
I'm not a geologist,
had geologists try to explain it to me
and uh,
that's what I'm trying to do here.
But uh,
yeah,
the,
uh,
the fact that these are enhanced,
these,
these things are quite enhanced at the
average rise and really depleted above
and below.
Now there are spheros throughout the
column,
one column of,
of soil.
When you go down vertically a deeper,
you find spheros.
Those spheros are typically what we call
orthogenic,
which means that are created by
terrestrial processes.
You need to do a scanning electron
microscope and
x ray,
a dispersive
spectroscopy to differentiate those from
the,
uh,
the terrestrial processes that are
producing these things.
Yeah.
Your figure five has a frand boydell
sphero,
which is probably what you're talking
about.
If you could go to slide 13,
jamie,
and,
and you'll be able to see.
Yeah,
there it is.
You can see very distinct difference.
So we've got your figure five up on the
screen now,
malcolm,
the
when,
when you look at optical microscope,
they look just like the are very much
like the,
uh,
the,
what we call impacts fuels are magnetic
microsphere rules and they occur much
more frequently.
I mean,
I've got,
I've got sites that have tens of
thoUsands of these things in every
couple of centimeters of sediment.
So you've got to separate the,
uh,
this,
the,
the impact spheros and the magnetic
microsphere oils from these things.
But what you appear to be saying about
them is that there is an abundance of
impact proxy evidence,
which in your opinion adds up to a
cosmic impact of some sort,
not necessarily a comment you're
suggesting an asteroid.
It's a mysterious event in that sense.
But what it adds up to is an impact in
your view.
Is that a fair,
a fair?
These,
what we call proxies,
the,
the impacts spherules the,
a platinum group elements,
the,
uh,
the melt glass,
which I haven't discussed yet.
And the nano diamonds are enhanced and
the enhancement has been replicated on
numerous occasions for each of these,
these proxies.
So anyone who says that the work of you
and your team has been completely
debunked is,
is clearly not completely familiar with
the literature that that's,
that would seem to be the case that are,
we're a disingenuous in that regard.
So I would say that that,
uh,
because typically what we see is that
the,
the opposition literature does not cite
the studies that have come out.
Yeah.
We try and cite both the critical
studies and ours and give reasons why
our studies supplant.
There's habit I wish they would share.
But,
uh,
could you go into hasn't been the case
slide 82.
It would be nice if we could have had
you on with mark so you guys can
exchange information.
But unfortunately our capabilities that
we can only take one phone call at a
time,
we will definitely try to update that
for the new studio.
Although we never anticipated this was
going to happen in the first place.
But uh,
are awesome.
Oh,
there we go.
Up on the screen.
Malcolm,
we've got
from ted bunch at our 2012 very high
temperature impact melt products as
evidence for cosmic airburst sandy
impacts 12,000,
900 years ago.
Uh,
so we have figure a supplementary
information,
six,
the light photo micrographs of magnetic
and glassy spherules from melrose,
Pennsylvania,
and it shows the,
the wide variety of shapes,
which includes spheros ovals,
teardrops in dumbbells.
And I think so you can see pretty
distinctly what you're talking about
here with the,
with the glassy spheros.
And then like particularly,
I don't,
I'm not sure if you were co author of
this paper or not.
You were not.
Okay.
Are you familiar with that paper?
Do you know?
The good.
Okay.
Yeah,
I chose some very interesting,
you know,
teardrop shapes,
dumbbell shapes and where you can
actually see that like dumbbell h up
there consists of two dissimilar
accretionary spheros,
one clear silicon rich and the other
opaque iron rich that have been fused
together.
And that's,
that's pretty convincing evidence of
the,
of the energy that's involved in these
phenomena that you actually have these
fused spheros like this.
And then jamie,
if you go down to the next image,
which is a scanning electron microscope
images comparing younger dryas boundary
spirits on the top row with known
impacts virals on the bottom row.
This is a very interesting comparison
because you've probably seen this when
malcolm a.
There's,
there's three across the top three
across the bottom and a is actually a
from knutson's or knudsen farm and
candidates,
a young cretaceous tertiary boundary,
sphero and just below it is a younger
dryas spiro from lakewood,
ceo in Mexico,
and one can see the morphological
similarity of the two quite clearly.
Then c and d compares a c is a spiritual
from the tunguska air burst,
and then d is younger dryas boundary
from lindzen,
Germany,
which dates to 12,800 years before
present.
And here you can see very clearly the,
the,
the rapid quench melt,
a texture on the surface between the two
comparison,
comparing togusa airburst with a younger
dryas boundary object.
And then finally enf,
we have an iron calcium silico sphero
from meteor crater compared with an iron
calcium silica younger dryas boundary
sphero from abou herea,
Syria.
And again,
in each of these cases you can see the
similarities between the different types
of objects.
So you have these three objects which
are come from that younger dryas
boundary layer,
all which have morphological similarity
to known impact proxies.
And this is very difficult to dismiss
this as being mere coincidence.
Yeah,
I would agree.
And uh,
those,
those are very,
especially the ac bed
pictures are very similar to the
material that I'm taking out of the
younger dryas boundary of the sites that
I've been looking at.
Malcolm,
what evidence,
if any,
are you aware of about what is that
nuclear glass material called trying try
to the trinity.
That's how you say it.
What I,
I,
from what I understand,
there's quite a bit of that that also
appears in the same time period.
And the core samples,
there are some instances of it,
but I wouldn't say quite a bit.
Some of these are very site specific and
one of the,
one of the things I've been trying to do
is work my way closer and closer to
Canada to see if there's any truth to
the,
to this whole idea that the primary
impact site was Canada.
So I've been trying to look at sites
closer and closer and I've seen sites in
New Jersey,
this would be eastern Canada.
I've seen sites in New Jersey,
New York and Pennsylvania that produce
a,
what appears to be some form of trinet
tight or,
or melt glass or what a ted bunch a
would call scoria like objects.
And it seems to,
to,
uh,
to bear out that,
that,
uh,
at least that far,
we're getting richer material out of the
sediment out of the younger dryas
boundary settlement.
Is this trinity
tights material only produced in this
manner?
It's also produced their nuclear
explosion test.
Right?
But other than that,
is this the only way that it's produced
on earth?
Well,
an impact would do it.
A or a full garage could delay.
What is the right is,
is what's produced by a pipe like a
lightening strike can produce
a,
a spherules that could produce all the
high temperature products that you see
an impact,
um,
but in a very limited way,
you wouldn't expect to see it in a,
in a layer less than was some sort of
global lightening storm.
Um,
the,
uh,
what I was going to say about the,
the melt glass is that in the material
we're looking at,
you see evidence of,
of melted,
a zircons,
melted chrome,
all of which are very high temperature,
uh,
features high,
indicating a very high temperature that
was experienced by that particular
object.
Or are you seeing the image we have up
here?
Yes,
I agree.
Okay,
good.
Okay.
Yeah,
there are a is for meteor crater and b
is from the trinity nuclear test.
So,
and then,
uh,
with the 22 kiloton yield and nancy is
from one of the soviet era nuclear
tests.
And d is again,
a scoria like object from apo hurriya.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So,
and then if we go to,
uh,
let's see,
um,
you gotta love that.
It says stalin,
I,
yeah,
jamie.
Maria,
like objects,
the,
uh,
the milk glass screen.
I like objects has only been found in
about half a dozen sites at this point.
So we're still,
you know,
and I think it's a matter of how close
you are to an impact point and you're
very far apart.
That would lend credence to the idea of
multiple impacts if they seem to be
getting more and more plentiful as you
get further and further north and maybe
there's more moral legitimacy to a,
to a primary impact site.
Right now.
We just don't know.
You know,
we're still,
we're still working that out.
All right.
We got another nice slide from,
from the bunch article here.
the slide.
Yeah.
Calcium oxide rich scoria like object
created by the melting of carbonate and
silica rich precursor rocks,
the yellow areas,
the calcium oxide,
the white areas,
le chateau earlier,
right.
And dark areas are iron oxide.
So that's a really nice.
Legit.
Yeah.
I had been struggling With getting that
down.
um,
and then jamie,
if you go to the next one,
we will see there is a scoria like
object for a meteor crater,
Arizona and you could toggle back and
forth between the two so that people can
kind of see the similarity between them.
And I see a lot in the sites that
produce milk glass.
that's what I'm seeing.
Yeah.
those two,
those two types of a particular 10,
how much of this material are you
finding in these sites?
Well,
you don't plan,
I have to say you don't find a lot of
this material.
It takes,
it's a struggle to get it,
but what you don't find is anything
above or below it,
that particular layer,
uh,
unless you know that there's been a very
dynamic environment which case it can be
spread out,
uh,
in the,
in the soil column.
And what's the implication of nothing
above it and below it.
Well that,
that,
uh,
you've got a specific date for a
specific date for it.
And,
uh,
the layer that we,
we typically try and just live at our
investigation to layers that have been
dated to the younger dryas boundary or
contained her dryas boundary layer.
Right?
But lIke I say,
if you have a very dynamic environment,
it can really screw things up.
Um,
you can be very difficult to interpret.
So this has been a lot of flooding,
repetitive flooding,
difficult science to do.
So again,
this is difficult science to do.
Uh,
yeah.
And,
and,
uh,
I should add there that proving an
impact is not easy.
It takes a while and,
and it just is proving an impact crater
is not easy,
as I'm sure mark would agree that you'd
find a crater.
There's no guarantee that's either an
impact impact a event or a or a volcanic
had been until you do the research and
spend the time to investigate it.
But if you could summarize for us what's
your opinion now on the balance of the
evidence?
Always bearing in mind that you may
change that opinion as more evidence
comes in.
Yeah,
I would say we were facing an
unprecedented type of event here that
appears to have been a,
something approaching global.
I mean we've got evidence now in south
America.
We've got evidence,
uh,
and a lot of this stuff is unpublished.
I mean,
I,
there's a lot of things that I could
bring up that aren't published,
so that is kind of useless to refer to
them because there's no way of checking
what I'm saying,
but we're seeing stuff that goes very
far into south America
and we're seeing things in Syria.
We haven't looked elsewhere.
We've seen about the pacIfic ocean,
we've seen it in europe.
So I mean where does it end?
And it's all.
We haven't found it yet.
And it's all at the younger dryas
boundary.
That's correct,
yeah.
What have you found in the pacific
ocean?
A while sharma has found.
So it was a paper I can cite from this
is a need,
just a presentation a quarter.
He says,
we infer that the central pacific was a
sign of deposition of osmium resulting
from dusk,
from dust cloud falling immediate
impacted 12,
$12,000.
Animals plus or minus $4,000,
so right in that,
right in that ballpark,
sharma says that,
uh,
he found osmium and I believe he's,
he's come up with microsphere met at
same core,
but uh,
so the central pacific is an idea that
gives you an idea of how extensive this,
this thing was.
Now malcolm,
this is obviously some controversial
material.
It's a,
it's,
it's fairly new in terms of the public
consciousness.
Have you had anybody debate you on this
or have you had anybody oppose you?
Yeah,
it goes with,
it goes with the territory.
I wish the,
uh,
the oppositions in some respects in some
cases.
I wish the opposition was a bit higher
caliber then.
And what I've seen,
I think it's,
uh,
it's been a sad state at a.
The most virulent opposition has not.
I have,
I haven't regarded as particularly I,
I quality
malcolm.
Michael shermer here,
just,
uh,
do you have an opinion on,
the,
the association of thE impact with the
megafauna extinction.
And also then grams hypothesis about the
extinction of this lost civilization.
The,
uh,
I really comment on the lost
civilization aspects of this.
I have a hard enough time dealing with
the media,
right impact,
uh,
as far as the megafauna goes,
I think that,
uh,
I guess I would say all of the above.
I think that all these factors came into
play.
You've got a humans who are,
you know,
for that period of technologically
advanced with,
with,
uh,
the clovis point and the,
the atlatl in the spear,
um,
the uh,
replaceable spirit tip that must have
been devastating to the foreigner,
but the,
the idea of attacking a,
a,
a proper sending to me is almost
unthinkable.
I mean,
those things are today.
If you don't have a high powered rifle,
I just don't see how you,
you realistically go up against the bull
elephant.
I mean,
it just strikes me as far too dangerous
a gone.
But,
uh,
there are aspects of that question that
I think are going to be very,
very interestingly the next,
the next couple of years or so,
we have a book coming out that addresses
that directly.
One of thE sites I've been researching
that,
uh,
the whole extinction of the megafauna
may have been as much related to
religion is something else.
There may have been a relIgion built
around the extinction of the megafauna.
Um,
how,
so that's well that
you'd want the evidence for that and
that,
that evidence will be coming out in a
book and that's going to be published in
about a month or two.
Oh,
I could speak to the whole idea of
hunting bull elephants,
though unfortunately,
people have been hunting with bows and
arrows forever.
Uh,
it's not an adult battle.
Atlatl is less effective.
You get less range,
but people hunt with not just modern
compound bows,
which are very powerful.
The w,
which would allow you to shoot it from
100 yards away.
But with long bows,
they've been hunting elephants with bows
and arrows for a long time.
You know,
especially the thing with wooly mammoths
was that they would go after the
females,
apparently according to dan flores who
wrote american serengeti and that the
females would keep the young in their
body.
Their gestation period was very long.
Like,
I believe you said it was two years,
is that correct?
I think you said it was two years and so
it made them extremely vulnerable when
they were pregnant.
Obviously if you kill off thE females
that are pregnant,
you're killing off a substantial part of
the breeding population and the
population suffers tremendously.
So that was one.
But it also could have been that and you
know,
that humans I'm sure had an impact on
virtually anything that we could eat
when we were starving.
But whether or not we wiped them out,
the blitzkrieg hypothesis,
there's a lot of holes in that theory.
According to,
uh,
a lot of people that have studied at.
Well I think,
you know,
if you have an environmental impact or a
degradation of the environment that
might follow a significant impact,
an extraterrestrial impact,
so you're,
you're reducing the population was
stressing the population of megafauna
that way.
And then you've got a population of
hunters in addition to that.
And especially if they're for some
reason or other focused on hunting a
sent ends.
And when the,
when the number gets limited,
they don't care whether it's a female or
a male and they go africa wherever they
can get,
then I think the population of
megaphones gonna suffer.
So I think it's a combination of
factors,
not necessarily just one.
Yeah,
I think that's very reasonable.
Malcolm,
is there anything else that you would
like to add before we let you go?
Uh,
no,
I,
I guess one thing is the interest.
I found it interesting in the discussion
of,
uh,
the uh,
the scab lands and,
and uh,
that was really,
it was looking at the scab lands from,
from flying over them when I was a young
naval officer that,
uh,
got me interested in science and why I
pursued science.
It was looking at that,
the catastrophes that were etched in the
landscape there,
uh,
the catastrophic floods that really
caused me to pursue a career in science.
It's really a remarkable.
It just a personal observation.
Well,
we're very,
very thankful for your time and we
really,
really appreciate your input here and it
means a lot.
And,
and thank you for everything you've
done.
Thank you for everything that you
continue to do to highlight this.
It is such a fascinating subject and
it's so amazing and without someone like
you presenting hard data in science,
it would definitely be lost.
So thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you,
malcolm.
Yeah,
thank you malcolm.
All right,
malcolm,
we're going to let you go.
Okay.
Take it easy buddy.
Sat down.
Time for your nap.
Malcolm.
It's a lot of energy.
So these podcasts are long.
I mean four hours.
The guy was sitting there on standby.
Probably,
you know,
chomping at the bit.
I'm jamie.
Before we go,
I want to see some pictures of the scab
lands because that is pretty amazing
stuff.
And randall,
one more thing before we go.
One thing that you pointed out to me
during one of the episodes that was so
stunning was these woolly mammoths that
had been literally knocked over by an
impact with broken legs and that died on
the spot.
Do you have those images?
I do it.
That was actually a mastodon mastodon.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
yeah.
I want to see those.
So let's go to the scab.
Lands first so we can show the audience
on youtube,
which is by the way,
only about 10 percent of the people that
watch this,
so if you're listening to this,
go check out the a scab lands on a on
google and you could see this.
Describe it to us,
randall.
Well here where this is
textbook,
scab land right here.
Let's see what this is.
Probably rock lake or sprague lake into
cheney.
Paloose.
Scab lands.
Yeah,
you see the potholes there.
That's a sign of turbulence.
Extreme turbulence within the water.
Coking is is what the process is called,
where you get it's so turbulent than it
actually produces vortexes.
High intensity vortex motion in the
water.
It'll pick up sediment and it can drill
its way right into the,
into the bedrock I'm going down there.
That's palouse falls,
which was say that's an under foot
waterfall because what you have to
realize is that at the peak of the
flooding,
this entire scene was submerged below
water and the cataract here is an
extinct feature and the flow over here
was thousands of times greater than the
present palouse river that you see right
there.
We've got a lot of great pictures up
unto geo cosmic rex website and some
awesome video clips.
I'm just curious,
are these geo cosmic rex?
Rex.
Okay.
And you were saying wreck like a car
wreck.
Well that's,
it's a play on words.
Um,
so yeah,
we are talking about that,
but yeah,
we got some great footage on
there.
I did.
We show that last time.
I believe we did the light of deadly.
Showed a bit of a chemist.
Prairie ripples.
Did we show potholes cataract?
Yeah.
This whole scab land thing is his
literally fascinated me since 1978 and
like malcolm and I think that summer of
1970 traveling out in some of these
landscapes.
Where you.
Yeah,
here we go.
Is the drone footage.
Wow.
Yeah.
And let's see,
be ready to pause you if we need to
hear.
Is this the beginning?
Because at the beginning we have a
google earth image.
She can get a sense of what we're
looking at here.
Go,
go back to the beginning,
right at the very beginning.
Let's see if it starts off with.
Oh,
it starts off with the drone.
Okay.
There should be another one that
actually.
That's okay.
This is pretty cool.
Yeah.
This is.
These are 400 foot cliffs.
This was a bomb recessional cataract.
Very similar to dry falls.
The water was pouring.
Coming from behind our view here.
Where's this specifically?
If anybody wanted to go watch this or
look at this area.
Oh,
the actual area.
This is an eastern Washington
eastern rim of quinty base and it's
called.
It's right along.
Just if you can see up there were those
cliffs are in the middle distance,
right below there is the columbia river.
And this is just north of wenatchee,
Wisconsin,
Washington.
So basically what we had here was
plucking a quarrying as the water poured
over this ridge.
This is the babcock ridge and behind us
as the quincy basin,
which served as a temporary holding
pond.
And let's see,
is the,
is the
drone comes around?
I'm looking for the um,
for the team.
Oh,
keep going to zoom in a little bit more
there.
Jamie.
she can see you guys down there on the
ground,
right?
Yeah.
Were they in there somewhere?
Lost in the vastness of the.
Yeah.
Now I remember we did show this.
What about those images of the
mastodons?
Let's look at tHose and then let's get
outta here.
Okay.
For that,
you have to go to the world of the
pleistocene,
which I just should have given you.
That sounds like a amusement park.
Yeah.
The world of the place is,
be some dudes with animal skins on them.
Well,
maybe if they stayed in,
you know,
cloning some of those frozen animals up
there.
Yeah.
I don't know how plausible it is,
but that seems like a terrible idea.
The last world,
nothing is any diseases.
Well that's one of the big concerns
about climate change,
right?
They we're going to release some
diseases that we don't have an immune
system for.
Yep.
Go to slide
78.
This is a good example of,
by the way,
who is more thoroughly documented than
randall carlson and jesus christ.
Man,
go to slide 6,220 to 50 plus years of
walking the walk in the channels
kavalans.
Uh,
yeah.
This,
this is a bone deposit.
Um,
and what happens is that in a
particularly warm years,
when the,
um,
the permafrost around thE rivers
collapses,
it exposes these huge deposits of bones
which had been buried in the permafrost.
This is,
when I look at stuff like this,
this is why I say there had to be
another mechanisms of extinction besides
human hunting because this pile,
yeah,
because it possible that this,
I mean,
it's not necessarily at the bottom of a
cliff,
right?
Because you know that they pushed a lot
of them off cliffs and know this.
THis is stuff that when the river
floods,
it erodes the banks and then this stuff
falls out of the riverbanks.
So it's,
it's been locked into the permafrost for
however many thousands of years and it
seems like there's interestingly two
peaks of dates that one right around
13,000 and the other one around $36,000
that,
that the,
that the fossilized remains are dating
too,
which could point to a potentially that
there was some sort of an impact back
then as well or something else,
some sort of event.
I,
I don'T know.
I don't have an opinion on now by having
all these together.
I mean has it been theorize that perhaps
this was at the.
This is not all your cliff near this,
right?
Yeah.
Just off the,
to the right,
to their interest.
There is a cliff where at the bottom of
a cliff right here.
That is actually,
it's a riverbank.
So,
so just off,
you know that that was a hunting method.
They used to storm them off the side of
cliffs and they never,
they literally couldn't even eat all of
them like head smashed in buffalo heads
smashed.
They would do,
they would run so many them off cliffs
that.
But here's the thing,
here's the thing,
when you look at at,
at the more these mortality events of
modern animals,
even like looking at elephants that
perished during some of the severe
droughts in the eighties in africa,
taxonomic studies show that it doesn't
take three,
four,
five years before the remains have
completely disappeared.
In order to preserve a fossil,
it has to be rapidly removed from any
kind of forces,
oxidation or scavenger or anything that
would consume it.
See,
this stuff has been,
again,
it's been frozen in the permafrost for,
for however many years,
10 or 12 or 15,000 years.
So it was likely covered in an event.
Covered in an event.
Yes.
Now what?
There was one that I really wanteD you
to get to that was a mastodon that had
been literally knocked over and had
broken legs.
Yeah.
That would be.
We could look very quickly at slide 92.
This is one of the more interesting
anomalous events.
This was the,
um,
the flash woolly mammoth.
Go to the,
go to slide 93.
It's a much clearer.
Yeah.
This was a mammoth.
SIx ton mammoth.
That was again,
one of these river collapses.
the banks collapsed during a warm spring
and expose this remains of a woolly
mammoth with soft tissue preserved,
uh,
contents of the food in its stomach on
digested actually a mouthful of food.
The hips of the mammoth where we're both
broken as if he was thrown back on his
haunches very violently.
He had an erect penis,
which suggests to us that he was
suffocated,
which he was a freak where he was
freaked out.
He was getting.
Michael laughed at that.
That's
the wolves ate the flesh off the skull.
That's why it's buried like that.
You'll see the front left for liam
there.
You'll see the bottom there left right
at the center of the screen.
That's his back leg.
Oh wow.
Did you see right there?
The interesting thing about this is you
know,
the,
the rapidity of climate change that's
implied by being able to freeze a six
ton mammoth because the contents of his
stomach,
according to the studies had not really
been purified yet,
which implies that the entire carcass
had been frozen through and through
probably in less than 10 hours.
Well,
like it see the ice man,
that's,
that's what happened to him.
That's exactly what happened to him.
Yes.
Interesting point.
In abu dhabi,
a subject that we should talk about,
it fell in between a crevice in a
glacier,
correct?
Yeah,
and probably got rapidly buried under
the under the snow and the ice and
that's how he ended up overnight
preserved.
Yeah,
overnIght.
Exactly.
The next slide actually shows her
reconstruction of the,
of the in,
in a,
in a museum in Russia,
showing what the mammoth,
the circumstances under which he was
found.
If you go to
as a sidebar on annuity ad to show you
how science changes rather slowly.
Sometimes it was a decade before they
found out he was murdered because they
found arrow point in his scapula.
Here they can cut is about annie had a
defensive wounds on his hands and arms,
so he'd gotten into a fight and he had
other people's blood on his hands,
so he gave as good as he got and lost a
fight.
So he was murdered.
Wow.
And that,
that took it with all that careful
observation and laboratories that 10
years before that came out.
Sometimes this stuff has to just take a
while.
So if I can try to find some common
ground with before we sign off with
graeme,
um,
you know,
you're uh,
your book is,
you have this really great sentence that
I quote this,
it would mean at least that some yet
unknown and identify people somewhere in
the world had already mastered all the
arts and attributes of a high
civilization more than 12,000 years ago
and sent out emissaries around the
world.
Okay.
I think this is entirely possible
cognitively for sure.
And
it Will do it for me.
What the boats that they sent the
emissaries out on the wood,
carbon 14 dated in some specific
examples of high arts and attributes of
high civilization.
So if it's not metal and writing,
then you know,
whatever it is,
I would change my mind.
That's good to hear michael.
And I think as the,
as the research continues in this area
for the last few years,
having been very much an outsider,
I have felt that the evidence is moving
in a direction that is helpful to the
argument that I make.
I hope it'll continue to be that way.
I hope the evidence that you're looking
for will,
will,
will come out.
And I'm trying to,
like I say my,
my,
my role is a reporter and I'm trying to
be a reporter for the alternative sides
of things.
But to do so to do so in an effective.
And hopefully
there's a good argument in the history
of science to be made for the role of
outsiders and mean complete outsiders to
come in and shake things up.
I mean freeman dyson as an example,
you know?
Yeah,
totally.
Self taught autodidact.
I called you an autodidact.
Absolutely.
And they can make.
And if nothing else,
they push people to really figure out
what it is they believe in.
Why?
Because otherwise no one's going to
challenge them.
So in births is a good example of that.
You know,
a high school teacher,
right?
However,
randall carlson is good example.
Well,
let's see.
You still want to look at this real
quick.
The mastodon I got right here.
Let's do it.
He could go for days about randall.
He never gets tired of this stuff.
If you could bottle your enthusiasm will
be an awesome pill.
Well,
maybe we can talk about the memory.
Focus there all.
Alright,
we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Look at this.
This mastered on here.
One 25.
Yeah.
So this is a mastodon that was dug up in
a pit years ago.
Um,
excavation showed that the bones were
lying on an inner layer of limey clay or
marble,
about one foot and thickness,
um,
when the,
when it gets up there and it goes on to
say the skeleton proved to be badly
disturbed and the bones crushed and
broken.
As an example of the amount of
disturbance,
one of the ribs lay beneath one of the
tusks.
While another was thrust through an
aperture in the pelvis,
a shoulder blade rested to the right of
the skull and one of the large neck
vertebrae was found about 10 feet from
the skull near a portion of the pelvis
in spite of the wide dislocation of the
parts the.
Now this is where it really is
interesting.
The bones of one of the feet remained
intact and in place very possibly in the
spot where the animal last step.
So in other words,
the foot,
there was a foot still embedded in the
soft material where he was apparently
stepping at the time,
whatever happened to them.
Um,
and this is all the same time period as
the other mastodon.
We don't have data on this,
but it,
it likely was at the very end,
probably right in that younger dryas
window because of the amount of sediment
over it goes to the next slide,
jamie.
And we'll see 1:26.
We can get a better than this thing
theoretically,
at least was blown back.
Yeah,
go to.
There we go there you can see one of the
femurs that's been busted squarely
across.
Um,
they go on to say that even the largest
of the bone such as the thigh bones were
broken squarely across in places
indicating that some considerable force
had been exerted upon them.
Any conclusion as to an agency powerful
enough to cause such destruction must be
highly speculative.
So basically what you're seeing here is
a mastodon that got smashed into the
ground.
Wow.
The forest is,
there were strong,
powerful sheer forces that would have
literally separated his leg from the
foot.
It still in immersed into the,
into the ground.
So I mean,
there are many examples of this.
The last slide we're going to show,
if you go back this,
I promise to digging with jack horner,
that paleontologists,
that dinosaur digger and he,
he showed these debris flow pileups of
dinosaur bones that had been splintered
and broken.
Wow.
And these are huge just from the force
of the water and then piling up at the
edge of a wall and sl if you can do it
to a dinosaur.
Wow.
Eighty 85
85 is an interesting slide because what
it shows is the london ivory docs,
which over a period of about two
centuries,
this was.
This was a mammoth ivory that's being
dug out of the siberian permafrost.
That's just a drawing.
Oh,
that's just a drawing.
That's the problem with that.
Like that's what it looked like.
A 19th century scene showing the ivory
floor of the london docks covered by
thousands of mammoth tusks and this went
on year after year after year after year
for roughly two centuries.
There is so much of that mammoth ivory,
by the way that they use it to make
knife handles.
I actually have a knife handle that I.
Yeah,
that was made out of mammoth ivory and
still to this day,
not only is it legal,
but it's common to use mammoth ivory for
different kinds of things and there's so
much of it.
Well,
they're not endangered species because
there was kind of a loophole in this
case though.
What we have is tucks that are being
again dug out of the permafrost.
So how did they get there?
That becomes the questIon,
does it have anything to do with human
predation or was it a natural
catastrophe that somehow ended up
putting all these mammas down and
burying them into permafrost?
That's the question I want to raise.
Well,
I think we raised a lot of questions.
I think we got some pretty good answers.
I think We had some great dialogue and I
really appreciate your time.
All three of you guys and thank you to
malcolm and thank you mark and thank you
to young jamie.
Oh,
thanks for hosting.
My pleasure.
Treat.
can I do a quick shout out out?
I want to thank brad young,
cameron,
wiltshire,
my brother,
rowan,
my wife julie for helping make this
possible.
I also want to have people go to the geo
cosmic rick's website and the sacred
geometry international website for a lot
more of this kind of stuff.
Then I'm going to thank my beloved
partner and wife santha,
who's chaired every adventure with me
for the last quarter of a century.
We climbed the great pyramid together.
We'd been at the bottom of the ocean
together and I wouldn't be doing any of
this stuff if it weren't for that
wonderful woman behind me.
Michael shermer,
who you want to thank.
Oh,
thank my wife jennifer,
my little boy vinny.
And uh,
my agent,
my.
No,
no,
but a skeptic.com.
And my partner pat,
who keeps the show running when I'm
running around doing things like this.
All right.
And joe rogan.
Joe.
I speak all over the world and whether
it's South Africa or whether it's Japan
or whether it's britain or whether it's
United States or whether it's Croatia.
People come up to me and they say,
Joe Robinson.
Yeah.
Well thank you.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate everybody's interesting
guests really.
Well.
You're one of them.
Do all you guys are.
Thank you so much.
All right.
We'll see you guys soon.
Thank you
so long.